Phoenix vor Ort
[Musik]
und ich begrüße Sie ganz herzlich es ist
wieder einmal soweit nach Lübeck
Magdeburg Essen und Gefahren im letzten
Jahr Marburg Cottbus Koblenz und Füssen
in diesem ist Olaf Scholz heute Abend
wieder in wenigen Minuten live im
Gespräch mit Bürgerinnen und Bürger und
wo findet das ganze statt im egerpark in
Erfurt und wo können Sie das live sehen
natürlich hier in wenigen Minuten bei
Phoenix und es geht dann eben um das
sogenannte kanzlergespräch andere kennen
ist eben auch unter dem Titel
Bürgerdialog 200 Thüringerinnen und
Thüringer sind mit dabei am Nachmittag
war oder Scholz übrigens das vielleicht
noch mal kurz angemerkt in Weitershausen
das ist in der Nähe von Gotha und hat
sich dort eine Firma mit Dichtungen
angeschaut eine Spezialfirma und hat
auch noch mal über das Thema
facharbeitskräfte und facharbeitskräfte
Mangel referiert Volker Kronenberg er
ist Politikwissenschaftler von der
Universität in Bonn wir schauen uns
gleich den Bürgerdialog zusammen an
vielleicht mal vorne weg was soll denn
dieser Bürgerdialog mit gerade mal 200
BürgerInnen und Bürgerinnen Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern bewirken was kann ein
Kanzler da erreichen
ins Gespräch kommen vor Ort sein mit 200
ausgewählten repräsentativ wie auch
immer Menschen in dieser Region dort in
diesem Bundesland ins Gespräch kommen
erklären Fragen beantworten Stimmungen
aufnehmen sorgen dann Antworten geben
befriedigende oder Fragen auch mitnehmen
Nähe zeigen erklären all das was vor der
Sommerpause immer wieder auch angemahnt
wurde was eher was die Regierung was
Politik leisten müsse besser leisten
müssen zu den Themen kommen wir gleich
noch jetzt sind wir aber in Thüringen
Erfurt und das ist ja nun für den
Kanzler alles andere ein als ein
Heimspiel wenn ich mir mal anschaue was
es dort in den Umfragen zu sehen gibt
AFD 30% plus teilweise und die SPD mit
Ohren 10% an vierter Stelle da wird er
sich einiges anhören lassen müssen
in der Tat und das ist Thüringen aber
wir haben die anderen Bundesländer dort
eben auch und da sind die
Herausforderungen ähnliche und wir
müssen jetzt dann nicht auf die
Linkspartei kurz könnte man auch aber
der Fokus im Moment in diesen Tagen
Wochen und ja Monaten ist gerichtet auf
die AFD und wenn wir man muss nicht
allzu viel auf Umfragen geben aber
gleichwohl sind sie natürlich an
Indikator wir haben von Sorgen
gesprochen eben oder Unzufriedenheiten
wie auch immer wenn man sich da die
derzeitigen Werte anschaut dann muss das
für jede Demokratie jeden Demokraten für
den Kanzler dieser Regierung natürlich
anders sein das umzukehren vielleicht
können wir einmal ganz kurz die Bilder
auch schon mal einspielen ich sehe es da
gerade da kommt der Bundeskanzler oder
Scholze gut gelaunt wie er ist er war ja
auch im Urlaub konnte sich das dann ja
auch dort einfach mal ein bisschen
Erholung ein bisschen Abstand von der
Politik aber die Sorgen bleiben ja die
gleichen Herr Kronenberg der Kanzler
wird sich natürlich auch noch mal fragen
müssen Energiepreise da kommt ja einiges
auf uns zu noch
das Thema brennt den Menschen unter den
Nägeln wie sind die Kostensteigerungen
es ist ja nicht nur das Thema Energie
anderer wir haben die Inflation und
anderes mehr und wir dürfen auch nicht
vergessen bevor er Urlaub gemacht hat
haben wir einen sehr selbst gewissen
fast allzu selbst gewissen Kanzler der
Sache AFD das wird sie wieder halbieren
wir haben alles im Griff die
Stimmungslage dort vor Ort in der
Republik scheint mir doch irgendwo auch
eine andere zu sein also für allzu viel
Lächeln ist glaube ich kein Anlassen
jetzt sehen wir gerade erst mit Applaus
begrüßt worden und jetzt können wir auch
direkt glaube ich schon mal in die
Veranstaltung reinhören wir haben einen
blauen Sommerabend bestellt den haben
wir schon mal bekommen das läuft schon
mal ganz gut ich freue mich dass Sie
alle hier sind wir begrüßen auch alle
die vor dem Bildschirmen sitzen ob im
Livestream auf bundesregierung.de oder
eben uns bei Phoenix zuschauen schön
dass Sie alle dabei sind und natürlich
begrüße ich ganz besonders die die hier
sitzen und dem Bundeskanzler schön dass
Sie da sind ja schön danke für die
Einladung
es ist dann das neunte kanzlergespräch
sie kennen das schon ein bisschen sie
sind jetzt hier heute in Thüringen die
Menschen die hier sitzen haben sich alle
beworben wobei beworben klingt so
verrückt nach man muss irgendwie zeigen
was man kann die Menschen haben gesagt
ich wäre gern dabei und dann sind sie
ausgelost worden es mussten vorab keine
Fragen irgendwie gemeldet werden und es
wurde aussortiert sondern es wurde
gelöst es wurde lediglich drauf geachtet
dass paribari Mann Frau vielleicht auch
aufs Alter und dementsprechend sitzen
diese Thüringerinnen und Thüringer jetzt
vor ihnen und ich bin gespannt welche
Fragen die Menschen aus meiner
Heimatstadt aus meiner Heimat haben ich
habe vorhin schon mal gesagt dieser
egapark bei mir weg der
Kindheitserinnerung diverse
Springbrunnen in die ich gefallen bin
darüber möchte ich jetzt nicht reden was
verbinden sie denn mit Erfurt
ich war hier schon öfter das ist eine
quicklebendige Stadt und ich war auch in
Thüringen ich habe sogar den Rennsteig
einmal durchgewandelt komplett
das ist stark
aber es war das eine Jahr wo es vom
Anfang bis zum Ende gerichtet hat
wenn Sie jetzt die Menschen fragen die
im Thüringer Wald leben oder eben nahe
des Rennsteigs die werden dieses Wetter
kennen da ist Sonne hier und da auch mal
eher die Ausnahmen aber ich bin mir
sicher das sind auch Menschen dabei die
öfter auf dem Rennsteig unterwegs sind
weil sie auch zum Thema Wald zum
Beispiel kommen wir sind gespannt wir
wollen auch gar nicht so lange vorher
drum rum reden sondern fangen einfach an
ähm mit Ihnen mit Ihren Fragen wer hat
denn eine Frage da gehen direkt so viele
Arme nach oben boah das stark also ich
wollte eigentlich sagen der oder die
erste wird aber das war jetzt nicht
auszumachen ich würde sagen wir fangen
an mit dem fröhlichen gelb und der Dame
ganz vorne und Peggy wird Ihnen das
Mikro bringen
schönen guten Abend der Bundeskanzler
mein Name ist Kerstin Hofmann und ich
bin seit ca 20 Jahren Geschäftsführerin
und Podologin in einer kleinen Stadt
hier in Thüringen
ich vertrete das Handwerk die
Dienstleistung und meine Frage geht
dahin gehend wenn sie zu mal in der
Bundesregierung über die
mindestlohnerhöhung z.B sprechen ob sie
da auch mal darüber nachdenken dass von
der Mindestlohn was ja von der eigens
eine gute Sache ist wenn der erhöht wird
aber letztendlich
[Musik]
brutto gar nicht so viel übrig bleibt
netto gar nicht so viel übrig bleibt wie
brutto und das
wir die Preise gerade beim
Friseurdienstleistungen immer weiter
Höhen müssen die Menschen nicht mehr
alle vier Wochen dann alle sechs Wochen
zum Friseur gehen und so weiter und ob
Sie das in Ihrer Überlegung einmal mit
einbeziehen danke schön schönen Dank die
Frage Mindestlohn hat mich schon lange
umgetrieben weil als wir den Mindestlohn
in Deutschland eingeführt haben und da
war er dann bei 850 da haben sechs
Millionen Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer eine Gehaltserhöhung
bekommen ziemlich viel das heißt ganz
viele haben viel weniger pro Stunde
bekommen für ihre Arbeit und jetzt wo
wir ihn auf 12 € erhöht hatten letztes
Jahr per gesetzesbewusst und sind wir
wieder im normalen erhöhungssystem drin
da war das dann auch so dass es noch mal
so viele waren die deshalb ein besseres
Gehalt bekommen haben
was glaube ich ja sie haben recht es
muss netto auch genug dabei rüberkommen
deshalb haben wir im letzten Jahr mit
Steuersenkungen nachgeholfen aber vor
allem mit einer Maßnahme die für
diejenigen wichtig ist die ganz ganz
wenig verdienen indem wir nämlich die
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge für
diejenigen die wenig verdienen bis knapp
2000 Euro erst allmählich ansteigen
lassen so dass netto mehr Nacht bleibt
das ist etwas was es sonst ja nicht gibt
der zahlen ja alle immer die gleichen
Prozentsätze egal wie hoch das Einkommen
ist aber unterhalb dieser
Einkommensschwelle ist es so dass wir
genau das gemacht haben aus dem Grund
den Sie in Ihrer Frage auch formuliert
haben und was die Wirkung betrifft für
die Preise klar aber da will ich mich
gerne bekennen ich finde wir müssen wenn
wir wollen dass unsere Nachbarn die
anderswo arbeiten gut zurechtkommen
können wollen dass sie wenigstens den
Mindestlohn verdienen wir wünschen uns
ja für eigentlich alle dass sie einen
höheren lohnen haben dadurch Tariflöhne
kommt und deshalb ist das aus meiner
Sicht richtig was ist das Gute am
Mindestlohn für die Wirtschaft
übrigens in vielen Untersuchungen
weltweit nachgewiesen gerade in Ländern
dienen auch erst irgendwann mal
eingeführt haben und früher nicht hatten
so wie wie früher auch nicht weil er für
alle gilt ist das Problem dass der
Wettbewerber der andere Unternehmer mit
Billiglöhnen dumping gegen einen machen
kann kleiner weil alle müssen ja
mindestens diese Summe zahlen und in der
Regel hat die Einführung des
Mindestlohns in allen Ländern in denen
das passiert ist zu einer erheblichen
Verbesserung von Wachstum und
Beschäftigung beigetragen und so war es
auch in Deutschland als wir es gemacht
haben und so ist es jetzt auch noch mal
gewesen also die Tatsache dass keine
Lohndumping Konkurrenz ist ist was Gutes
auch für die kleinen mittelständischen
Betriebe die sonst obwohl sie in
Beschäftigten gerne mehr zahlen würden
das nicht machen könnten und das hat
sich eigentlich überall so rausgestellt
ich bin also unverändert der Meinung gut
so und dass wir so viele Menschen hatten
die so wenig verdient haben das war das
Problem und es ist ja unverändert so
übrigens kann man hier ja auch sagen am
meisten profitiert von der
mindestlohnerhöhung haben die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger im Osten
Deutschlands
dann würde ich doch mal sagen wir machen
hier drüben weiter mit dem Herrn im
dunkelblauen Jackett
guten
Kraft wie passt es zusammen dass wir in
Deutschland die Kernkraftwerke abstalten
und jetzt teuren Strom aus Frankreich zu
kaufen importieren und der Kernkraft
oder es kann Kraft erzeugt wird
schönen Dank für die Frage weil es mir
die Gelegenheit gibt mal mit ein paar
Gerüchten aufzuräumen also im letzten
Winter haben knapp die Hälfte der
Atomkraftwerke in Frankreich nicht
geliefert weil sie kaputt waren und
überarbeitet werden müssen und es sind
noch nicht immer wieder alle heil
und wir haben Strom nach Frankreich
geliefert durch den ganzen Winter mit
deutscher Windkraft mit deutschem
Kohlestrom mit deutschen gaststrom und
mit deutschen Atomstrom also ziemlich
viel ist aus Deutschland rüber geflossen
jedes Jahr gibt es aber Phasen in dem
wir auch Strom aus anderen Ländern
einkaufen und obwohl wir ziemlich viele
Kohlekraftwerke
wegen des letzten Winters und weil Putin
kein Gas mehr geliefert haben wieder
angeschaltet haben und jetzt im
Augenblick so viel Kohlekraftwerke im
Betrieb haben wie seit Ewigkeiten nicht
nicht für immer aber jetzt für den
Übergang wo wir diese Bedrohung
bekämpfen mussten
wird er gerade nicht gekauft weil es
billigeren Strom aus anderen Ländern
gibt also wir haben nicht genug nicht zu
wenig
Stromerzeugungskapazität sondern einige
haben gesagt da gibt es billigen
Windstrom aus den Niederlanden da gibt
es billigen Atomstrom von da da gibt es
billigen Strom von da nehme ich den doch
lieber als den vom gastkraftwerk und
deshalb ist in der Gesamtbilanz die Lage
ganz anders und das will ich auch mal
sagen ich bin ganz froh dass wir uns in
Deutschland für die billigere
stromproduktionsvariante entschieden
haben denn wenn sich jetzt jemand
entscheidet er möchte ein neues
Atomkraftwerk bauen dann trifft er eine
Entscheidung die wenn ich die Preise von
heute zugrunde liegt mindestens 15
Milliarden pro Stück kostet
wahrscheinlich 20 und da kriegt man dann
Strompreise weit über 20 Cent in der
gestehung hin wenn wir bei Windstrom in
Preisen sind wo wir die Chance haben
dass das unter zehn Cent kommt und das
ist glaube ich der Grund warum wir mit
der Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien der
Windkraft der Solarenergie und unsere
Stromnetzes die billigere langfristige
Variante getroffen haben und auch eine
die schnell zur Verfügung steht wenn wir
jetzt sagen würden wir wollen ein neues
Atomkraftwerk bauen
die sind müssten alle neu gebaut werden
nein ich habe alle gefragt man kann die
nicht wieder einfach in Betrieb nehmen
das ist wie ein Neubau also aber wenn
wir sagen wir würden ein neues bauen
dann könnten würden wir wahrscheinlich
sagen kostet 20 Milliarden und es sind
15 Jahren fertig
aber wir wollen schon 2030 80 Prozent
unseres Stroms aus erneuerbarer Energie
haben billiger und schneller verfügbar
deshalb die Antwort
wir gehen den besseren Weg
dann machen wir doch mal direkt hier
weiter ich stehe so nah dran ihre Frage
bitte
schönen guten Tag Herr Bundeskanzler
mein Name ist Julia braban ich komme aus
Erfurt und ich möchte Sie fragen im
Blick auf die antidemokratischen
Tendenzen die wir gerade hier in
Thüringen wahrnehmen aber auch weltweit
warum kürzen Sie die Gelder in ihrer
Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung
und im Kinder- und jugendplan im
nächsten Jahr laut Haushaltsplan so
massiv ich weiß es soll auch andere
Demokratie bildende Maßnahmen geben aber
braucht es nicht demokratiebildung
braucht es nicht den Austausch
miteinander um Welt zugewand zu leben
und den Anti demokratischen Tendenzen
auch entgegenzuwirken statt zu kürzen
danke für die Frage und noch mehr danke
für den Beifall wenn ich das dann alle
anderen sagen darf das ist ja sehr
wichtig dass wir etwas für Demokratie
Förderung tun wobei ich ganz klar sagen
will das ist nicht die Antwort auf Ihre
Frage die kommt noch aber das mit der
Demokratie klappt weil wir als
Demokraten Demokraten das wichtig finden
das geschieht nicht weil es ein
Bundesprogramm zur Demokratie Förderung
gibt sondern weil wir alle ein
persönliches Programm zur Demokratie
Förderung sind und uns dafür einsetzen
dass wir in einer Gesellschaft leben in
der wir selber über unsere Zukunft und
unsere Geschicke bestimmen und in der
wir auch miteinander leben können obwohl
wir ganz unterschiedliche Vorstellungen
haben aber gerade weil wir über die
Demokratie unsere Unterschiedlichkeit zu
einem gemeinsam
Zukunft in Deutschland bringen können
ist das das Beste was man überhaupt nur
haben kann
was die Demokratie Fördermaßnahmen
betrifft werden wir die auch weiter
haben auf die verschiedensten Weisen
gleichzeitig müssen wir mit unserem Geld
auskommen und das ist dann immer so dass
hin und her und dass der Bund das macht
ist richtig genauso wie das die Länder
und die Kommunen das machen weil das ja
im wesentlichen Aufgaben sind die dort
vor Ort stattfinden aber ich habe mich
immer dafür eingesetzt dass wir uns
nicht raushalten obwohl wir nicht
zuständig sind so und das finde ich ist
auch richtig so deshalb können Sie sich
darauf verlassen nicht dass alle Summen
immer so sind wie sie alle gerne hätten
aber das ist immer viel sein wird und
dass es uns wichtig ist
dann gucken wir mal hier in die Runde
direkt
schön gelandet
Auto ich komme aus Erfurt und ich möchte
unseren Bundespräsidenten kurz zitieren
der heute ein Ansprache gehalten hat zum
75 jahrestag des Verfassungskonvent von
1948 damals zum Herrn Chiemsee und hat
unter anderem mit aufgeführt Demokratie
fallen da haben in unserem Land momentan
starken Zulauf und die
Vertrauen in die Regierungspolitik singt
immer weiter und meine Frau und ich wir
haben wir sind der Meinung dass
Demokratie wird unterwandert und auch
sehr missbraucht das wollen Sie dagegen
nein die Demokratie dass die
unterwandert wird das will ich mal nicht
hoffen aber es gibt schon Gegner der
Demokratie auch im politischen Spektrum
und da werden wir uns nicht davon
drücken können dass wir dann auch
gegenhalten und sagen dass wir eben die
Demokratie und die Freiheit die wir uns
erworben haben auch verteidigen und für
mich gehört dazu aber auch dass wir uns
klar werden worum es da geht es geht
darum dass wir sagen dieses Land hat
sehr davon profitiert dass wir in der
Europäischen Union sind die deutsche
Einheit wäre ohne die EU ohne die
Europäische Union nie zustande gekommen
denn nach zwei Weltkriegen die von
Deutschland ausgegangen sind haben sich
echt viele gefürchtet dass wenn wir
wieder ein Land werden das eine riskante
Sache aus Sicht unserer Nachbarn ist uns
wieder zu solcher Stärke und Kraft
aufwachsen zu lassen haben sie aber
gemacht wegen der EU und das glaube ich
dürfen wir nie vergessen dass es diesen
Zusammenhang auch gibt und dass der uns
sehr geholfen hat und der große
Wohlstand den unser Land hat hat auch
sehr damit zu tun dass wir uns nicht auf
den Export und auf die Produktion für 84
Millionen Leute die in Deutschland leben
beschränken müssen sondern dass wir die
ganze EU mit ihren weit über 400
Millionen Einwohnern haben und dann noch
aus dieser Basis weltweit mit unseren
mittelständischen Betrieben konkurrieren
können ich war heute gerade bei einem
Betrieb hier der sich mit Gummi
beschäftigt der hat Kunden in aller Welt
und zwar immer schon muss man dazu sagen
und deshalb gehört das schon dazu dass
wir diese Offenheit und auch als Stärke
für uns gewinnen und zur Freiheit und
Demokratie gehört dass wir einander
beschützen dass wir dafür sorgen dass
niemand wegen seiner Meinung sich
fürchten muss und dass man das was wir
politisch miteinander zu diskutieren
haben auch eben politische demokratisch
miteinander beredet was mir wichtig ist
ist dass wir in einer Zeit in der viele
Dinge viele unsicher werden lassen
sehr schnell immer klar machen dass wir
eine ein Kurs verfolgen der uns
Sicherheit geben kann und bei dem wir
zuversichtlich in die Zukunft gucken
können wir hatten die corona-pandemie
das war eine große Herausforderung bis
in die Lebensverhältnisse da haben sie
auch viele in jeder Familie gestritten
und alles mögliche hat stattgefunden
dann dachten wir sie sind jetzt durch da
kam der russische Angriff auf die
Ukraine mit vielen Konsequenzen auch
vielen Bürgern und Bürgern und nicht nur
den Eltern die sich große Sorgen machen
und Angst haben das muss man ja auch
dazu sagen was das wohl bedeutet da sind
wir jetzt dabei mit vielen Freunden
zusammen die Ukraine zu unterstützen
klug abgewogen jeden Schritt sorgfältig
Bedenken so dass man darin vertrauen
kann dass wir das richtig machen aber
wir haben auch die ökonomischen Folgen
aus
pendeln müssen alle dachten der Winter
wird kalt alle dachten die Betriebe
müssen alle schließen das haben wir
alles verhindert weil wir dafür gesorgt
haben dass obwohl uns 50% unser Gast
Lieferung plötzlich fehlten bei Russland
sie eingestellt hat wie sie aus
Westeuropa kriegen über Norwegen und
über neugebaute norddeutsche Damens und
jetzt gucken wir dafür dass wir nach
vorne kommen und bei Zuversicht wichtig
ist ein Stichwort gerade entscheidet
sich
dass die Halbleiterindustrie die nicht
so richtig Fuß gefasst hat jedenfalls
nicht im großen Maßstab in Europa
überwiegend in Deutschland stattfindet
in Magdeburg die größte
Direktinvestition in der Geschichte
Europas aus dem Ausland die größte in
der Geschichte
in Dresden sehr sehr viel da sind
mehrere Entscheidungen jetzt eine neue
von TSMC und Verbündeten aus Deutschland
infineon hat in Dresden gebaut global
foundrys hat
ausgebauter das sind unglaublich viele
Arbeitsplätze mit verbundenen Saarland
gibt es eine Fabrik die neu gebaut wird
von Wulf Speed und das alles findet
statt und ist vielleicht ein Grund zu
sagen ich glaube die Tatsache dass wir
gute Kraft haben tolle Ingenieuren und
Ingenieure gute Unternehmen und viele
tolle Arbeitnehmer und Arbeitnehmer wird
schon dazu beitragen dass wir
zuversichtlich bleiben können und das
ist dann das zweite neben der
Verteidigung der Demokratie was man
braucht damit die Welt zusammenhält hier
in Deutschland
okay
wenn du mal bitte bei der Dame genau mit
dem gemusterten Kleid
ja schönen guten Tag mein Name ist Doris
Oswald ich komme aus Erfurt lieber
Bundeskanzler ich habe eigentlich 24
Fragen in der Tasche tja ich würde Ihnen
genau ich würde gerne eine stellen das
war mein Plan und die anderen 23 würde
ich ihn gerne mitgeben das ist
vielleicht beantworten können
meine Frage ist der Bundeskanzler sie
und ihre Minister haben ein Eid abgelegt
ich denke sie kennen den Eid ich muss
sie nicht vorlesen dass Sie alles zum
Wohle des deutschen Volkes und so weiter
tun würden
durch die Politik der Regierung entsteht
der Eindruck dass diese Eid vergessen
wurde Herr Lauterbach scheint der
Pharmaindustrie zu dienen Frau bärburg
erklärt den Russen den Krieg was nicht
im Sinne der deutschen Bürger ist und
der Habeck hat es geschafft das Land in
ein das das Land ein Negativ
Wachstum aufweist das geht aus den
Berechnungen des Kieler efe-institutes
vor oder heraus was tun Sie dass Ihre
Regierungsverantwortung gegenüber dem
Volk gerechte werden wieder wird schönen
Dank für die Frage
und wenn ich die jetzt richtig sehe
könnte ich die ganze übrige
Veranstaltung alle Sachen die da so
angesprochen sind beantworten das haben
sie geschickt da alles reingemogelt
deshalb will ich ein paar antworten
geben aber nicht alles was man dazu
sagen könnte sagen also das erste ist
Herr Lauterbach die nicht der
Pharmaindustrie ich weiß gar nicht wie
sie darauf kommen ich kriege ständig
Beschwerdebriefe von der Pharmaindustrie
dass er ihnen ein paar
Gewinnmöglichkeiten weggenommen hat und
für die Leute die sich damit auskennen
kann man sagen das Stichwort lautet am
Nord das ist eine Form wie die Preise
festgesetzt werden den Gesundheitswesen
jedes Mal wenn ich mit einem Chemie und
pharma-chef spreche kommt er auf dieses
Thema zu sprechen also stimmt gar nicht
und Frau bärbock hat auch Russland nicht
den Krieg erklärt keinesfalls sondern
Deutschland macht eine sehr
verantwortungsvolle Politik russland hat
die Ukraine angegriffen und zwar aus
einem ganz tiefen imperialistischen
Motiv die wollen einfachen Teil von dem
Land für sich sowas wie wir das im 17 18
und 19 Jahrhundert hatten und das muss
man auch gar nicht rumrätzen das hat der
Putin alles öffentlich gesagt und
aufgeschrieben und aufsetzen und hat das
nach Kriegsbeginn in einer Rede
ausführlich auch noch mal erläutert er
findet eigentlich die Ukraine und auch
Bilder Russ und deshalb fürchtet sich
sogar sein Verbündeter Herr Lukaschenko
vor ihm gehören eigentlich zu Russland
und er will sie haben
und zwar mit einer Idee die wenn alle
das hätten die Welt in Brand setzen
würde denn tatsächlich ist es doch so
dass die Grenzen die wir in Europa heute
haben Grenzen sind die sind jetzt so
gekommen aber wer sich mal so ein
bisschen die Atlanten 50 100 200 300
Jahre rückwärts anguckt der wird von
vielen Ländern finden dass sie gute
Gründe haben zu sagen ein Teil des
nachbarritoriums wäre eigentlich ihrs
und wenn das alle machen würden dann
wäre hier ein Brand den wir nicht mehr
gelöscht kriegten und das ist das
Gefährliche an dem russischen
Angriffskrieg das nachdem wir dachten
wir sind und zwar über viele Dinge nicht
einig und ganz unterschiedlich aber das
Grenzen nicht mehr mit Gewalt verschoben
werden das ist ein Konsens den wir haben
und den hat er in Frage gestellt
trotzdem beachten immer drauf dass wir
bei all den Entscheidungen die wir
treffen verhindern dass es zu einer
Eskalation des Krieges zu einem Krieg
zwischen Russland und der NATO kommt
sondern das ist ein Krieg bleibt
zwischen Russland dass die Ukraine
angegriffen hat und der Ukraine die sich
verteidigt aber dabei bei uns von uns
unterstützt wird und was die Wirtschaft
betrifft habe ich ja eben schon gesagt
da stimmt ja manches nicht zusammen
der Wirtschaftsminister hat gerade
gesagt er hat an Anfragen wo er ein
bisschen helfen soll für Investitionen
in Deutschland gebündelt 80 Milliarden
Euro Investitionen
ganz schön viel ich habe gerade über die
vielen Investitionen in die
Halbleiterindustrie in Deutschland
gerade im Osten Deutschlands gesprochen
überall werden batterie-fabriken gebaut
hier auch in Thüringen wird die die
schon da ist sogar auch noch erweitert
ThyssenKrupp viele andere
Stahlunternehmen Salzgitter demnächst
auch ArcelorMittal mit den Standorten
auch im Osten Deutschlands wollen alle
investieren in die Art und Weise wie man
Stahl produzieren kann ohne dass man
Kohle dafür einsetzen muss damit wir
auch weiter Stahl haben aber CO2 neutral
alles das findet statt aber was jetzt
einige quasi schlecht machen ist das was
uns stark gemacht hat und deswegen noch
mal sagen Deutschland ist eine
Exportnation und als Exportnation können
wir natürlich nicht verhindern dass mal
die Wirtschaft anders wo schwächelt und
die nicht so viel bei uns kaufen der
Maschinenbau auf den wir in Deutschland
so stolz sind exportiert 80% seiner
Maschinen in alle Welt und zwar immer
schon und es gibt keinen
Konjunkturprogramm dass wir machen
machen können um dafür zu sorgen dass in
China oder in Vietnam oder in Indonesien
jetzt die Maschinen gekauft werden außer
dass wir sicherstellen dass sie weiter
erste Klasse sind dass die Ingenieuren
Ingenieure das gut machen dass unsere
Unis gute Leute ausbilden dass wir gute
Berufsausbildung haben und dass alle mit
dem Herz dabei sind und auch die
Maschinen den 30 Jahren gebraucht werden
vielfach aus Deutschland kommen und
daran aber arbeiten wir
machen direkt weiter hier vorne einmal
Paul die kriegen sie
guten Abend der Bundeskanzler mein Name
ist Franziska Hildebrand und ich bin im
Bürgermeisterin von einer kleinen
Gemeinde hier in der Nähe klettbach im
Weimarer Land
in der Kommunalpolitik sind wir ganz
ganz nah an den Menschen dran wir
kriegen alles sofort gespiegelt und wir
kriegen nicht nur das gespiegelt was wir
bei uns vor Ort machen sondern halt eben
das was auch auf Bundesebene passiert
und in letzter Zeit und das wird immer
stärker ist einfach die Rückmeldung dass
ich die Menschen nicht mehr mitgenommen
fühlen
diese Entscheidung die viel auf im
Bundesebene getroffen werden ich sage
nur wir hatten schon Atomausstieg
Verbrennermotor
heizungsgesetz etc das sind alle Sachen
wo sich die Menschen nicht mehr
mitgenommen fühlen das ist eine große
Schwierigkeit die ich bei uns sehe und
ich denke dass die die Menschen
verlieren immer mehr dieses Vertrauen in
die Politik
die Entscheidung die auf Bundesebene
getroffen werden die funktionieren
vielleicht in Berlin und in München
vielleicht auch in Erfurt und in Jena
aber gerade hier in Thüringen im
ländlichen Raum haben wir ganz andere
Herausforderungen die wir lösen müssen
was wollen Sie tun damit dieses
Vertrauen in die Politik und auch in die
Bundespolitik wieder da ist
wir leben in Zeiten großer Umbrüche und
Umbrüche machen immer Sorgen und Angst
dafür habe ich auch großes Verständnis
alles andere wäre auch ungewöhnlich und
ich habe auch schon früher immer wenn so
Leute an sagen alle wollen doch dass ich
ständig aus was ändert die meisten
finden alle Änderungen ständig
Modernisierung super wie gesagt macht
mal eine Umfrage wenn die Leute wählen
können alles bleibt wie es ist oder es
kommt anders würde es immer eine
Mehrheit geben lass es bleiben wie es
ist allerdings ist das ein schlechter
Rat den man sich selbst meistens dann
doch nicht gibt und wir uns als Land
auch nicht geben dürfen deshalb mal zu
den Dingen die sie angesprochen haben
das ist ja auch gut so
die amerikanische Automobilindustrie
setzt auf Elektroautos
japanische Automobilindustrie setzt auf
Elektroautos die koranische
Automobilindustrie setzt auf
Elektroautos die chinesische
Elektroautos und wir haben Verbrenner
und machen auch sehr sehr gute finde ich
übrigens mittlerweile Elektroautos
wenn man jetzt so tut als ob das der
komische Einfall von irgendwem in Berlin
ist dass wir jetzt auch elektroautos
haben müssen kann ich nur sagen wenn wir
diesen Rat folgen würden in Deutschland
wenn Daimler Volkswagen BMW fort
Tesla Brandenburg riesige Fabrik gebaut
das auch alle glauben würden
dann würden wir wahrscheinlich demnächst
große Armut haben und unser
Automobilindustrie würde den Bach
abgehen und deshalb investieren die alle
hunderte Milliarden in den Ausbau ihrer
Fähigkeiten solche Fahrzeuge zu bauen
von denen wir uns als Bürgerinnen und
Bürger wünschen dass sie nicht nur diese
antriebsdynamik haben und leiser sind
als das was wir kennen sondern dass sie
irgendwann auch nicht mehr kosten als
das was wir von den Verbrennern kennen
und natürlich das ist eine gute lade
Infrastruktur gibt so dass man überall
in Deutschland das auch machen kann und
das muss jetzt unsere Aufgabe sein aber
es kann ja bis 2035 jeder noch ein
Verbrenner kaufen und danach auch noch
eine neue hergestellt werden Sie bei uns
dann nicht mehr das ist so quasi die
Wirkung außer ein paar die mitfahren
wollen das werden wir mal sehen ob das
viele sind aber die halten dann ja auch
noch 20 Jahre also der Übergang ist
schon ganz schön lang und in der Zeit
aber
zeigen wir was wir können nämlich dass
wir genauso gut mit unseren Unternehmen
das machen kann mein Satz ich war in
Köln
da die Firma Ford also ich nehme jetzt
bewusst kein deutsches
Automobilindustrie seit Ewigkeiten schon
ich glaube seit den 20er Jahren
Automobile gebaut größtes Werk in Europa
wenn ich es richtigen Kopf habe kann
falsch sein aber ich habe so im Kopf
die haben da immer bisher ein Auto
gebaut und ich war jetzt dabei als diese
Produktion stillgelegt wurde und
demnächst ein elektrischer fort übrigens
auf einer Basis von Volkswagen also die
Plattform gebaut wird und das ganze Werk
wird dieses Fahrzeug jetzt bauen weil
die sagen dass das Beste
und das ist glaube ich das was wir im
Kopf haben müssen das ist jetzt nicht so
eine Idee von irgendwem sondern das ist
das was eine gute Zukunft hat und
natürlich braucht es gute
Übergangszeiten eine gute Infrastruktur
und es muss bezahlbar sein da sind wir
uns völlig einig das gilt auch für die
Industrie wenn wir glauben dass es für
uns genug Kohle Gast und Öl gibt wir uns
einige einreden dann werden wir uns
gekniffen haben
ich meine was wir gegenwärtig sehen das
macht ja einigen sogar Angst weil die
Welt dadurch besser aber
auch für uns
nicht immer einfacher wird
Milliarden Menschen steigen auf in
Wohlstand wie wir ihn haben in Asien
in Afrika im Süden Amerikas
das war früher nicht so da waren wir
ganz alleine und haben über diese Länder
und deren wirtschaftliche Lage uns
besorgte Gedanken gemacht aber da gibt
es jetzt Fabriken da wird Stahl
hergestellt und Chemie gemacht da gibt
es Automobilfabriken da werden
Lokomotiven gebaut da werden Häuser
errichtet und Universitäten und schienen
errichtet und Autobahn und Milliarden
Menschen werden ein Wohlstand haben
wollen der so ähnlich ist wie der den
wir hätten haben
und man stelle sich meine Sekunde vor
irgendwo in den nächsten 20 30 40 Jahren
haben fast alle Menschen auf der Welt
und das werden um die Mitte des
jahrhundert zehn Milliarden sein
so ein Wohlstand wie wir ihn 1950 hatten
der Kampf ums Öl
der Kampf ums Gas
der Kampf um die Kohle wenn wir nur das
machen würden der wäre die Preise wären
sehr sehr hoch und wenn dann alle so
viel imitieren würden wie wir in den
letzten 200 Jahren dann kriegten wir das
mit dem Atmen auch nicht mehr so richtig
hin und deshalb ist es einfach wichtig
dass wir jetzt auf Technologien setzen
die dazu führen dass unser Wohlstand in
Zukunft größer ist als heute und dass
wir gleichzeitig dazu beitragen können
dass das Klima und die Umwelt geschützt
werden so dass wir auch gut da leben
können denn ich bin für Wachstum um das
ganz klar zu sagen aber ich finde
Wachstum muss nicht so sein dass man
gewissermaßen dann schlechter lebt und
das finde ich ist das was wir jetzt
hinkriegen müssen für uns in Deutschland
übrigens eine gute Chance denn wenn wir
es sind die die Technologien können
dann können wir sie auch verkaufen und
Wasserstoff Elektrolyse können wir schon
seit 100 Jahren jetzt müssen wir das nur
so skalieren dass es billig und im
großen Maßstab geht und das gleiche gilt
für die Windkraftanlagen die in
Deutschland gebaut werden die sind
Weltspitze und neun gibt es mittlerweile
sogar Unternehmen in Europa die sagen
wir können und in Deutschland Forschung
die können viel bessere Solarpanele
bauen als sie in China gebaut werden
also unsere Chancen sind schon ganz
schön gut aber es ist eine Zeit des
Umbruchs und da wundere ich mich nicht
wenn Leute fragen haben und sich nicht
alle sicher sind dass der Weg richtig
ist aber ich bin dafür dass wir auf das
setzen was wir in Deutschland immer gut
konnten unsere Ingenieurinnen und
Ingenieure unsere Wissenschaftler und
Wissenschaftler unsere Unternehmern
Unternehmer und die unglaublich vielen
guten Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
in Deutschland
ist Ihre Frage damit beantwortet es ging
ja um Zurückgewinnung von Vertrauen der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ich persönlich
bin so ein Stück weit eher der Meinung
dass ich gute Ideen durchsetzen wenn sie
gute Ideen sind und nicht aufgrund von
Verboten von anderen Ideen ja Verbote
bin ich auch nicht für und deshalb
machen wir es ja auch ohne Verbote
überwiegend
so wir springen mal da hinten hin der
Mann im weißen Hemd
Paul
guten Abend Herr Bundeskanzler mein Name
ist und ich komme aus einer der
schönsten Landkreise hier in Thüringen
nämlich dem Eichsfeld
meine Frage sie hatten gesagt dass der
Wohlstand in Deutschland sehr hoch ist
was sicherlich auch stimmt
meine Frage geht in die in die Rente
warum unsere Rentner die ja wirklich
auch
sprichwörtlich gesagt ihr Brot gegeben
haben in vielen Jahren Arbeit wird am
Ende ihre Rente besteuert warum ist das
in Deutschland so
wollen sie da was ändern dass die Renten
irgendwann auch mal ja auf einem Niveau
sind wo die Rentner auch sagen können da
kann ich von Leben wie viele Rentner
gibt es bei uns in Deutschland die von
ihrer Rente noch nicht einmal leben
können
mit ihnen und mit allen die Beifahrer
geklatschern bin ich der Meinung dass es
schon ganz schön gut dass wir die
gesetzliche Rentenversicherung haben das
ist eine gute Tradition in Deutschland
und wir müssen auch dafür sorgen dass
sie eine gute Zukunft hat und das hat
sie auch da bin ich nämlich anderer
Meinung als die Skeptiker die uns immer
mal wieder in den Leitartikeln
verschiedener Zeitung mitteilen alles
geht schief das sind die gleichen
Skeptiker die uns das auch schon Ende
der 90er Jahre mitgeteilt haben und man
kann im Hinblick auf diese Fachleute
sagen sie haben sich alle verrechnet
sie haben sich alle verrechnet nach der
Meinung der Fachleute Ende der 90er
Jahre würden wir jetzt Beiträge zahlen
die über 25% bis 30 Prozent
Rentenbeitrag sind wir sind bei 20
drunter noch im Augenblick
wir haben Vorhersagen gehabt dass alles
nicht mehr finanzierbar ist weil wir
weniger Arbeitnehmer haben werden
tatsächlich haben wir sechs Millionen
mehr wir haben die höchste Zahl von
Erwerbstätigen in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland nicht nur in
der Geschichte Deutschlands 45 Millionen
wir haben die größte Zahl
sozialversicherungspflichtiger
Beschäftiger 34 Millionen jemals
und deshalb geht es auch mit der Rente
besser als alle vorher gerechnet haben
weil so viele Leute arbeiten und
Beiträge zahlen Aufgabe das für die
Zukunft zu sichern
und damit das mit dem Rentenniveau
klappt haben wir jetzt viele
Entscheidungen getroffen eine dass wir
jetzt erstmal bis 25 gesichert haben das
Rentenniveau wird stabilisiert die
zweite habe ich mit meinen Partnern
vereinbart wir werden das verlängern und
zwar auf sehr sehr lange Zeit damit sich
alle darauf verlassen können dass das
Rentenniveau stabil bleibt und nicht
sinkt
drittens wir haben dafür gesorgt dass
diejenigen die viel gearbeitet und wenig
verdient haben eine bessere Rente
kriegen mit der Grundrente die jetzt
Stück für Stück vielen zugute gekommen
ist
viertens glaube ich weiß nicht wo ich
gerade bei der Erzählung bin aber wir
haben
auch entschieden das wäre eine
Erwerbsminderungsrente kriegt weil er
oder sie ist nicht durchgehalten hat bis
zum Renteneintritt zu arbeiten weil man
krank war oder irgendwie sonst eine
Beeinträchtigung hat die das nicht
möglich macht besser gestellt werden
indem wir so tun als hätte man bis zum
Renteneintritt mehr oder weniger
gearbeitet für die die neu reingehen und
im letzten Jahr leider völlig
unberichtet von irgendwem oder höchstens
hinten auf Seite 14 irgendeiner Zeitung
haben wir für alle
Erwerbsminderungsrentner nachträglich
die Renten angehoben also lauter
Entscheidung die dazu beitragen dass es
besser läuft als es ohne all diese
Maßnahmen wären und die sind ja alle
ziemlich teuer denn alles zusammen
zahlen wir im Augenblick 120 Milliarden
Euro aus dem Bundeshaushalt in die
Rentenversicherung ein damit das stabil
bleibt übrigens gibt es von mir auch
noch eine klare Ansage ich bin der
festen Überzeugung dass wir es jetzt
nicht mehr nötig haben das
Renteneintrittsalter immer weiter
anzuheben wer jetzt mit 17 die Schule
verlässt hat fünf Jahrzehnte Arbeit vor
sich ich finde das ist genug wenn dann
wenn dann jemand findet ich will auch
länger super aber nicht weil er muss
sondern weil er oder sie kann
also die Besteuerung ja nicht dass sie
das Vergessen ja die Frage habe ich
schon oft beantwortet ich habe leider
nur irritierte Blicke geerntet und ich
werde das jetzt wieder tun
das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat eine
Entscheidung getroffen an der wir nicht
vorbeikommen
und zwar hat ein Beamter geklagt und der
Beamte hat gesagt ist doch fies dass ich
als Beamter auf meine Pension Steuern
zahlen muss und die
sozialversicherungsrentner nicht
und er hat das bundesverfassungsleiter
richtig leider zu unserer vollständigen
Überraschung gesagt er hätte recht
natürlich hat er gedacht er müsste jetzt
keine Steuern mehr zahlen aber das geht
ja nicht und deshalb ist es jetzt so
dass wir in einem ganz langen Prozess
den wir bis jetzt noch mal verlängern
ein Umstieg machen
der bedeutet
seit Anfang diesen Jahres das haben wir
vorgezogen alle Beiträge die man zur
Rentenversicherung zahlt vom
steuerpflichtigen Einkommen abgezogen
werden das war bisher nicht so und das
ist jetzt hundert Prozent
und dann ist es so dass wir so ein
Übergangsprozess haben jedes Jahr kommen
paar dazu wo man sagt ein bestimmter
höhere Anteil von dem Einkommen ist
jetzt gewissermaßen noch unbesteuer also
besteuert gewesen oder unbesteuert
gewesen und deshalb steigt der
steuerbare Anteil in der Rente Stück für
Stück und wir wollen jetzt diesen
Zeitraum von 240 wo das zu Ende geführt
wird auf zwei 60 verlängern
und das ist dazu da damit wir das Urteil
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts umsetzen
können wenn Sie mich fragen ob es das
gebraucht hätte nein aber ich beachte
immer alle mit allen Respekt
Entscheidungen des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts
okay dann bringen wir doch mal nach da
vorne und nehmen mal die junge Dame mit
Sonnenbrille im karierten direkt vor dir
Annika
guten Abend herr Scholz mein Name ist
Annika Retter ich lebe in Erfurt seit
sechs Jahren und engagiere mich
ehrenamtlich beim Thüringer
Kinderhospizdienst
den gibt es
denn viele Familien mit lebensverkürzt
erkrankten schwerstbehinderten Kind oder
Kindern erfahren sehr wenig
Unterstützung im Alltag es gibt
vereinzelt in Deutschland Kinderhospize
das sind nicht in erster Linie Orte zum
versterben der Kinder sondern in erster
Linie Orte der Erholung für die gesamte
Familie das lebenslimitiert erkranken
kinders meine Frage weshalb werden
Hospize für Erwachsene
die im Wesentlichen für der Begleitung
des lebensendes da sind gefördert und
wieso werden Kinderhospize dagegen gar
nicht staatlich finanziell unterstützt
sondern müssen sich zu einem sehr
geringen Teil über die Kosten die Pflege
und Krankenversicherung erstatten
finanzieren aber zu einem größeren sehr
hohen Anteil über spendenfinanzieren wo
doch Kinder eigentlich das Wichtigste in
unserer Gesellschaft sind in kinder sind
die Zukunft
zunächst mal will ich ihn völlig Recht
geben was die Arbeit von Kinderhospizen
betrifft ich habe sehr viele schon
besucht und einige auch konkret
begleitet über manche Jahre da wo ich
lange gelebt habe in Hamburg zum
Beispiel gibt es eines das sehr sehr
engagierte aber ich kenne auch andere
und das ist etwas ganz ganz berührendes
zu sehen wie da mit Engagement
gearbeitet wird aber auch zu sehen wie
das für die Kinder und für die Eltern
eine ganz große Stütze ist einer
wirklich sehr sehr schwierigen Zeit ich
bewunder all diejenigen die da was
machen ich will ihn jetzt ganz verblüfft
sagen dass ich von einer
unterschiedlichen Förderung von
Kinderhospizen und Erwachsene Spitzen
nichts weiß aber ich werde mich der
Frage anzuwenden ich bin nicht sicher ob
das so ist aber auf alle Fälle wäre das
etwas was mich nicht überzeugt und
insofern danke ich ihm für die Frage und
ich gehe der Sache nach
das finden wir gut auf jeden Fall etwas
was Sie mitnehmen können Herr
Bundeskanzler und bekommen mal zu dem
Mann hier vorne mit rosa Hemd
ja wir werden jetzt immer Männer mit
rosa Hemd und sowas ne ja ok gut wenn
ich kann damit leben Herr Bundeskanzler
mein Name ist Olaf braun ich bin seit
vielen Jahren ehrenamtlich beim DRK
aktuell der
landeskatastrophenschutzbeauftragte im
Landesverband Thüringen mich bewegt
gerade das Thema zivil und
Katastrophenschutz die Konzeption zivile
Verteidigung sagt ja dass wir für ein
Prozent der Bevölkerung
betreuungs- und Unterkunftsmöglichkeiten
vorhalten sollen und dazu wurden die
mobilen
behandlungsmodule entwickelt eins ist
mittlerweile als Pilot beim DRK
angesiedelt neuen weitere sollen kommen
ein Modul kostet 30 Millionen in diesem
Haushalt in diesem Jahr sind 15
Millionen angesetzt im nächsten Jahr wo
das Modul 2 bis 5 kommen soll sind 6
Millionen angesetzt ich mache mir Sorgen
allem die Finanzierung und um die um den
wirklichen Ausbau dieser wichtigen
Angelegenheit denn wir haben es im
Ahrtal gesehen wie schnell wir für viele
viele Betroffene und so ein Modul ist
für 5000 Betroffene autark einsetzbar
wir brauchen unter Umständen relativ
schnell sowas und da ist eben die Frage
wie sieht's zukunftsmäßig mit diesem
Modulen aus und vielleicht noch
hinterher geschoben zehn Module für
Deutschland also nicht in jedem
Bundesland kommt eins das
thüringenministerium hat signalisiert
Thüringen wäre bereit ein solches Modul
am Standort zu halten auch die
Standortfrage ist auf bundeseben nicht
geklärt meine Frage vielleicht noch mit
dazu
welche Chancen stehen dass wir in den
nächsten Jahren damit rechnen können
schönen Dank für die Frage noch den
Hinweis auf den zivilen
Katastrophenschutz und die Notwendigkeit
da vieles vorzubereiten ich habe mir das
im a-tal ja auch genau angesehen ist uns
wie viele furchtbare Zerstörung dort
angerichtet worden sind und wie viele
Menschen ihr Leben verloren haben und
alles was sie besetzen haben
aber natürlich auch was für ein
unglaublichen Einsatz bis an die Grenze
ist von ganz vielen die überall aus
Deutschland dahin gefahren sind gegeben
hat damit man Menschenleben und die
Situation retten und die Situation
meistern kann und weil wir ja unsere
Fähigkeiten auch anderswo einsetzen wenn
zum Beispiel Erdbeben sind und andere
Katastrophen weiß ich dass wir ganz gute
Ausgangsbedingungen haben aber dass wir
in einer Welt die unsicherer wird und wo
wir auch damit rechnen müssen dass die
Zahl der Umwelt Katastrophen z.B zunimmt
auch bei uns sicherlich nicht jetzt
einfach zu warten dürfen und sagen wird
schon so reichen wie bisher deshalb
berichten sie zurecht von dem Plan was
auszubauen und der wird mal schneller
und mal weniger schnell vorangehen das
wird ein bisschen was mit
Haushaltsmitteln zu tun haben aber der
Bund und die Länder und die Gemeinden
haben da eine Aufgabe dass jeweils da wo
ihre Zuständigkeit ist auch
voranzubringen und wir bekennen uns auch
dazu also wir wollen das und deshalb
sind jetzt auch überall vorbereitet dass
die notwendigen Standortentscheidungen
getroffen werden manche verstehe ich
auch nicht da melde ich mich dann als
Bundestagsabgeordneter bei der
Ministerin und dem Minister die
zuständig sind und so wird es Ihnen
wahrscheinlich auch gehen und dann muss
man gucken dass wir das so Stück für
Stück zurecht mendeln damit das für ganz
Deutschland eine gute Struktur gibt
wir machen direkt weiter hier drüben
vielleicht mal Sabrina hiervon die
jungen Dame die einen langen Zettel
hatte ich mit dabei um möglichst kurze
Frage damit wir so viele wie möglich
schaffen hallo Herr Schulz mein Name ist
Carolin kürbs ich bin 37 Jahre alt habe
zwei wundervolle Kinder und bin mit Herz
und Seele eine Physiotherapeutin ich
habe mich vor anderthalb Jahren mit
Corona angesteckt und Co wird entwickelt
und mein Leben hat sie um 180 Grad
geändert
ich habe kann keine Treppe mehr steigen
ich bin seitdem nicht wieder auf Arbeit
gewesen kann meine dreijährige Tochter
nicht mehr hochheben denn da so ein Land
gerade schwimmen ist die kleinste
Belastung bekomme ich Luftnot
Erschöpfung und lege manchmal tagelang
im Bett es sind in Deutschland bis zu 2
Millionen Leute betroffen wird Postfach
und mcfs viele könnten gar nicht heute
an so einem Gespräch dran teilnehmen
weil sie im Bett liegen ich bin froh
dass ich heute hier sein kann auch der
Zettel deswegen das kognitive das ist
auch immer das Problem
und habe den Betroffenen die ich auch
persönlich kenne Fragen gestellt was
würdet ihr heute den Kanzler stellen und
es waren so viele tolle Fragen und
Antworten herr Scholz warum gibt es noch
keine Medikamente Therapien warum machen
die Leute Ambulanzen zu die Menschen
liegen im Bett und werden vergessen weil
sie nicht können
herr Scholz ich habe so viele tolle
Fragen bekommen auch verzweifelte Fragen
eigentlich müssten wir zweimal einen
Kaffee trinken gehen aber meine
persönliche Frage und die muss ich jetzt
leider ablesen wie wollen Sie
sicherstellen dass wir langzeitkranke
angemessen mit medizinische Versorgung
erhalten und gleichzeitig besser sozial
abgesichert sind um unsere finanzielle
Belastung zu bewältigen danke schön
ich weiß es gibt ganz viele die noch
heute unter den folgenden Erkrankung
bleiben und auch
das ist ja ein sehr großes Feld wie das
dazu kommt dass man diese Spätfolgen
entwickelt und selbstverständlich ist es
so dass wir mit der Forschung nicht so
weit sind dass wir für alle Fälle
wirklich wissen könnten was da die
richtige Therapie ist und was man machen
kann das darf uns aber nicht dazu führen
dass wir jetzt die Hände in Schoß legen
ich kenne auch jemanden persönlich der
nur noch im dunklen Raum sein kann und
kaum Geräusche verträgt und alles
mögliche und das ist ein sehr netter
lebenslustiger junger Mann also insofern
will ich dazu sagen das ist schon eine
reale Tatsache und all denjenigen die
sagen das gibt's doch gar nicht den will
ich sagen doch das gibt und die
simulieren auch nicht wie einige
behaupten sondern wirklich schwer krank
und für manche und ziemlich viele davon
wissen wir noch nicht was das Beste ist
um sie von diesen Spätfolgen der
Infektion zu therapieren dass sie wieder
fröhlich am Leben teilnehmen können
deshalb haben wir jetzt zusätzliche
Bundesmittel bereitgestellt um die
Forschung zu diesem Thema voranzubringen
aus dem arbeiten wir sowieso aber auch
mit Wirkung für diesen Bereich daran
dass wir das Forschen in Deutschland im
Bereich der pharmazeutischen Industrie
und der Therapien leichter machen also
der Bundesminister Lauterbach will jetzt
zum Beispiel dafür sorgen dass wir alle
Daten nutzen können wir haben
gegenwärtig nicht die Möglichkeit alle
uns digital verfügbaren Daten
tatsächlich immer durch Computer laufen
zu lassen ob sie uns irgendwelche
Erkenntnisse vermitteln das machen wir
aber jetzt das Gesetz ist jetzt
unmittelbar in Vorbereitung das wird uns
sehr viel helfen weil wir von anderen
wissen dass das Auswirkungen hat und wir
brauchen natürlich auch unbürokratische
Verfahren wie man
Medikamenten Zulassung Medikamenten
Forschung betreiben kann also mehr hat
neulich mal jemand gesagt wenn ich diese
Forschungsreihe machen will und so viele
Patienten in Deutschland testen will
dann kann es mir passieren dass ich zig
Ethikkommissionen fragen muss und lauter
unterschiedlichste Genehmigung brauche
bis ich da durch bin das ist natürlich
absurd und deshalb habe ich gerade
gestern mit dem Bundesminister
besprochen dass wir jetzt ein Gesetz auf
den Weg bringen dass diese Dinge neue
regelt damit die Pharmaforschung und
auch die universitäre Forschung viel
viel einfacher wird und wir
unbürokratischer und das machen und
nicht 20 Institutionen jeweils eine
Genehmigung geben müssen bevor es
losgeht und ein paar Sachen sind auch
schief gelaufen das geht noch mal auf
die Daten ich habe mal mit einem
Medizingeräte Hersteller gesprochen ein
sehr berühmten der hat gesagt das
Training unser Geräte machen wir an den
Daten der Kranken Haus Patienten in
Mexiko City
weil sie in Deutschland die Genehmigung
dafür nicht kriegten so das ändern wir
jetzt also um das mal so zu sagen und
was die neben dem Forschungsmitteln die
postcode erkranken betrifft
zeigt sich dort ganz besonders ein
Problem das nicht ganz einfach zu lösen
ist aber über das ich immer schon so
viel weiß dass ich darüber was sagen
kann
wir haben ja sehr viel Sicherheit in
unserem Gesundheitssystem verlassen sich
auch alle darauf das ist auch sehr gut
dass man eigentlich wenn man einen
Medikament kriegt ziemlich sicher sein
kann dass es in alle Richtungen getestet
und geforscht und
überprüft worden ist
aber wenn ich jetzt drei Jahre im
dunklen Raum sitze und mich nicht mehr
richtig bewegen kann aber es gibt
Medikamente die vielleicht helfen würden
aber erst in fünf Jahren sind alle Tests
abgeschlossen so dass es für mich
verfügbar wäre
dann ist das vielleicht etwas wo wir
eine andere Praxis entwickeln müssen und
Medikamente die noch nicht sicher und
nicht abschließend getestet sind mit
Einwilligung der Patienten verfügbar
machen wenn der Arzt oder die Ärztin und
man selbst das möglich findet weil das
ist ja auch dann für jemanden unangenehm
zu hören es gibt ein Medikament da ist
jemand als Testperson gewesen bei dem
hat das voll gewirkt
aber ich kriege es nicht das ist gerade
in ihrem Bereich ein Thema und da müssen
wir was machen und dann wollen wir auch
was machen und jetzt könnt ihr noch zwei
Stunden weiter reden das lasse ich aber
weg ich will nur sagen Sie haben recht
das ist ein großes Thema und Sie können
sich aber sicher sein dass wir mit
großer großer Sorgfalt versuchen im
großen aber auch in ganz konkreten was
postcode wird betreffen
da war noch die Frage nach der
finanziellen Absicherung langzeitkranker
finanziell das Loch also jetzt noch
anderthalb Jahren das ist wirklich also
man fällt ja selber privat in ein
finanzieller Service man hatte sich was
aufgebaut ein Haus gebaut und jetzt die
Absicherung jetzt nach anderthalb Jahren
ich wäre gerade ausgesteuert weil jetzt
ins Arbeitslosengeld und was kommt
danach also man hat sich ja das auch
nicht ausgesucht ja also ich finde da
haben sie ein Thema das ja an vielen
Stellen von Leuten die langzeiterkrankt
sind sich stellt es gibt dafür Lösungen
auch in unserem
Sozialversicherungssystem aber die sind
ziemlich bürokratisch mühselig und
setzen viele Kenntnisse über das System
voraus ein bisschen kenne ich mich aus
weil ich mal Arbeitsrecht und
Sozialrecht gemacht habe bevor ich
Berufspolitiker wurde 13 Jahre lang also
da habe ich eine Ahnung von aber ich
will gerne sagen dass verdient eine
genaue Betrachtung wenn sie mir im
Anschluss vielleicht ganz konkret ihr
Problem schildern können das dann für
mich exemplarisch wäre wo die Übergangs
Probleme bei der Finanzierung sind das
würde ich gerne verstehen weil
theoretisch gibt's für alles eine
gesetzlich vorgeschriebene Lösung
praktisch weiß ich Hacks oft sonst hätte
ich als Anwalt kein Geld damit verdient
diese Probleme zu lösen aber vielleicht
können wir das Thema ja einfacher machen
so dass man auch ohne Anwalt klar kommt
würde ich so als Anwalt sagen ja klingt
doch fast nach einem kurzen
ich wechsel mal die Perspektive weil ich
damit ich hier hinten damit er nicht
heißt ich habe hier hinten niemanden
gesehen vielleicht die junge Dame mit
den Palmen und Blumen auf dem Shirt
ja erstmal vielen Dank für die junge
Dame
also mein Name ist Carolin Hüttner ich
komme hier aus Erfurt und
sie haben vorhin gesagt dass das
Deutschland gut geht
da gebe ich Ihnen Recht in bestimmt
vielen Bereichen aber es gibt durchaus
auch Bereiche wo es in Deutschland gar
nicht so gut aussieht
nicht umsonst müssen wirklich viele
Rentner noch arbeiten müssen arbeiten
das machen sie nicht immer noch nicht
freiwillig uns wird doch auch noch sehr
lange dauernd Jugendclubs müssen
geschlossen werden weil kein Geld da ist
jedes Kind soll ein Kindergartenplatz
erhalten oder einen Kita-Platz wie es
heißt davon sind wir auch noch sehr weit
entfernt
auf oder in Pflegeeinrichtungen müssen
ganze Stationen geschlossen werden weil
einfach kein Geld für Personal da ist
bzw auch kein Personal da ist ich könnte
die Reihe jetzt noch fortsetzen
andererseits
stellt sich das
für den ganz normalen Bürger so da wenn
man das Fernsehen einschaltet und dann
sieht wie Frau bärburg durch die Lande
reisst und die Millionen
anderen Ländern verspricht wir
unterstützen Sie hunderte von Millionen
medienwirksam dann auch noch durch den
Strand läuft über den Strand barfuß
läuft und
[Musik]
das ist meiner Meinung nach für den
Normalbürger der vielleicht unter diesen
Dingen leidet das eben nicht genügend
Geld für viele andere Bereiche da ist
schwer nachzuvollziehen warum dann
andere Geld rausgeworfen werden
rausgeworfen
wo doch Deutschland selber dringend
bräuchte selbst die Stadt Erfurt braucht
dringend Geld
und ich denke dass das auch eine Ursache
ist dafür ist warum es die
ich sag's ungern die AFD so viele
zuläufer hat
das ist nicht das ist nicht vermittelbar
für den der abends die mda-nachrichten
schaut oder welche auch immer und
dort wird das Geld rausgeworfen
ich zitiere das höre ich immer in meinem
Umfeld
und andererseits fehlt es in manchen
Bereichen an allen Ecken und Enden
rentnerklubs werden geschlossen und so
weiter und so fort
ja schönen Dank
ich will
zunächst mal sagen
das ist natürlich ganz viele Dinge gibt
für die man viel mehr Geld ausgeben
könnte das weiß ich aus allen
Ämtern die ich schon mal hatte also als
Senator in Hamburg als Bürgermeister als
Arbeitsminister in Deutschland als
Finanzminister und jetzt als
Bundeskanzler ich könnte lange Listen
anlegen was man alles noch ausgeben kann
das einzige was man weiß wenn man diese
Listen liest und sie auch viele wichtige
Punkte beinhalten es wird nie eine Zeit
entstehen in der es nicht eine lange
Liste gibt die man selbst bei der besten
Haushaltslage komplett bearbeiten könnte
und natürlich ist es auch
unterschiedlich
was man will oder was man richtig findet
also zum Beispiel als ich Hamburger
Bürgermeister war habe ich gesagt ich
finde alle Schulen müssen top sein also
haben wir sehr viel Geld da reingesteckt
weil wir ja für die Gebäude zuständig
waren und haben dafür gesorgt dass es
genug Schulen gibt und das ab einem
bestimmten Zeitpunkt ich glaube der
kommt jetzt der Umbau von allen
abgeschlossen ist so dass die Neubau
Niveau haben ich habe viel Geld in Kitas
gebührenfreie geht das gesteckt ich habe
dafür gesorgt dass es genug Plätze gibt
und Ganztagsangebote
nun ist die
Stadt und das Bundesland dass ich
regiert habe auch wirtschaftlich und
finanziell ganz gut dabei aber trotzdem
bevor ich die Verantwortung hatte sind
andere Entscheidungen getroffen worden
das war also eine
prioritätenentscheidung das wichtig zu
finden und das können wir natürlich in
einem Land mit
Bundestag und Bundesregierung die für
bestimmte Aufgaben zuständig sind 16
Ländern ich glaube über 500 Landkreise
und kreisfreien Städten über 11.000
Gemeinden nicht alles einmal durch
Regeln sondern setzt schon voraus dass
wir vor Ort da wo wir jeweils zuständig
sind bestimmt Dinge selber wichtig
finden zum Beispiel fand ich immer
wichtig sozialen Wohnungsbau als in ganz
Deutschland gesagt wird den brauchen wir
gar nicht mehr habe ich viel mehr als
was ich an Bundesmitteln bekommen habe
zusätzlich eingesetzt um rechtzeitig ein
großes Bauprogramm auf den Weg zu
bringen wo das auch eine Rolle spielt
also müssen wir auch über das was ist
uns wichtig was machen wir mit dem Geld
was wir haben diskutieren
bestimmte Dinge werden schwierig
und eins muss man ganz offen sagen wenn
wir was für unsere Sicherheit tun wollen
das müssen wir wenn wir erleben dass ein
sehr großes Nachbarland einfach sein
anderes großes Nachbarland überfällt das
größte Land in Europa Russland überfällt
das zweitgrößte Land in Europa die
Ukraine dann müssen wir mehr Geld für
Verteidigung ausgeben das werden wir
anderswo spüren da will ich niemanden
den Eindruck erwecken als ob das
folgenlos bleibt wenn wir das machen
trotzdem sage ich eigentlich haben wir
nicht in jedem Jahr nicht überall und an
jeder Stelle viele Möglichkeiten
andererseits weiß ich es gibt Gemeinden
die Pfeifen auf dem letzten Loch weil
die Wirtschaft dann nicht so gut läuft
die Steuereinnahmen nicht groß genug
sind und das mit dem Kommunalen
Finanzausgleich das nicht ausgleicht
und dann müssen wir dafür Sorge tragen
dass es bestimmte Dinge gibt wo wir
Unterstützung leisten können das machen
wir auch mit dem digital-programm für
Schulen mit bauunterstützungsprogramm
die wir haben mit verschiedenen anderen
Dingen die eine Rolle stehen beim Kita
Ausbau damit man nicht alleine bleibt
mit so einer Aufgabe und das werden wir
auch immer weitermachen müssen und
müssen uns richtig drum bemühen dass wir
das gemeinsam hinkriegen was die
Entwicklungshilfe betreffen
das müssen wir machen
ohne das Geld
zum Fenster raus zu werfen
es müssen wir machen
aus vielen Gründen einmal
weil das
unsere Verantwortung ist die wir
empfinden dass wir nicht allein sind auf
der Welt und wenn es Millionen Menschen
gibt die kurz vorm Verhungern stehen was
der Fall ist
wenn es Millionen Kinder gibt die nicht
wissen wo sie zur Schule gehen sollen
und das sind alles viel größere Zahlen
hat sich jetzt sage dann können wir
nicht sagen das ist uns egal sondern
dann finde ich schon dass wir da
mithelfen müssen dass die Dinge sich
vernünftig entwickeln können
und deshalb wird es immer ein Teil
unserer Aufgabe sein auch
mitverantwortlich zu sein für eine gute
Entwicklung anderswo in der Welt das
muss man mit Augenmaß tun und muss auch
immer gucken ob die Sachen auch wirklich
hilfreich sind das will ich ausdrücklich
dazu sagen das wird man auch immer
wieder neu diskutieren müssen aber dass
wir uns vor dieser Aufgabe drücken
können das glaube ich nicht und deshalb
sollte man nicht das eine gegen das
andere ausspielen sondern versuchen das
möglichst gut zu machen aber auch
natürlich gucken wie kann man
Prioritäten so richtig setzen dass da wo
sich hierzulande Bürgern und Bürger
bedrängt fühlen und sagen da fehlt was
was wir eigentlich machen müssen dass
wir das irgendwie hinkriegen ein Thema
haben sie angesprochen bei der Pflege
z.B das will ich kurz noch erwähnen da
fehlt es uns in der Tat an
Arbeitskräften und da müssen wir was
dran ändern mit Ausbildung mit
Weiterbildung mit attraktiveren
Arbeitsbedingungen ich habe mir immer
gemerkt das ist eine schwere Ausbildung
die brauchen ja viele Jahre bis sie den
Beruf haben und dann wechseln alle im
Schnitt nach sieben acht Jahren
da läuft was schief das müssen wir
besser hinkriegen denn wenn die nur
zwölf Jahre blieben oder sogar für bis
zur Rente hätten wir schon weniger
Arbeitskräfte Mangel in diesem Bereich
also hilft es für gute
Arbeitsbedingungen zu sorgen damit das
irgendwie funktioniert und dann werden
wir wohl ein paar Fachkräfte aus anderen
Ländern holen müssen wenn so viele von
uns in Rente gehen und nicht genug junge
Leute an diese Stelle treten weil wir
nicht so viele Kinder gekriegt haben wie
zu der Zeit als wir beide geboren wurden
so ist das da werden wir jetzt was draus
machen müssen
wir haben noch guten halbe Stunde Zeit
es sind so viele arme oben und ich frage
mich ob ich die Richtige für den Job bin
ich war nämlich schon immer schlechte
Entscheidung also aber gut wir gehen
einfach mal einen Tisch weil wir waren
noch gar nicht an dem Tisch und ich
würde sagen weil eben zwei Frauen dran
waren ah der Mann
mein Name ist Bürgermeister also ich
heiße so
ich war mal einer ich bin es nicht ich
bin es nicht also erstmal vielen Dank
für die Gelegenheit für reden zu dürfen
und auch für einen Besuch hier in Erfurt
ich bin von der Sprache her kein
Thüringer ich bin eingewanderter Schwabe
seit 2013 und 2016 auch hier
verheiratet mit einer Thüringerin und
sehr gute Entscheidung das stimmt also
die Frauen im Osten und im speziellen in
Thüringen die haben was muss ich echt
sagen ich kann ja ein Vergleich machen
zwischen West und Ost und ich habe da
auch eine etwas längere Liste aber es
dreht sich darum ein Punkt der steht
gleich auf der ersten Position im
Zusammenhang mit meiner Frau
die ist fünf Jahre älter wie ich wir
haben eine Umdrehung von diesem
typischen Erscheinungsbild man älter wie
Frau jetzt ist die seit
20/2020 in Rente die hat ihre 45 Jahre
voll und kriegt jetzt ihre Rente das ist
würde ich sagen vernünftig ist aber
nicht genug sie hat dann zu einer
Zeitpunkt
wo dann die Politiker Gilde in Berlin
spricht man einfach so ein bisschen
uncharmant aus ist geduldet hat dass zum
Beispiel in wutha-fan oder bei einem
Hersteller von elektronischen Geräten
die man als Kartenlesegerät nimmt im
Laden oder so was in dem Fall ist es
ingenio 5,40 verdient hat in der Stunde
in der Nachtschicht mit Zulage was dazu
gehört
da hat sie dann Rentenpunkte verdient
zwischen 0,3 und 0,85 im Jahr ich habe
mir da also sehr intensiv damit
beschäftigt und mit diesem Berater von
Renten kann sie sehr lange telefoniert
so da hat sie da das heißt dann
offiziell
Jusos zur Grundrente weil sie das über
eine gewisse Zeit lang gemacht hat jetzt
hat diese Politikerkaste ist erstmal
geduldet dass man 5,40 € bezahlt hat in
der Nachtschicht mit allen möglichen
Zuschlägen jetzt ist die Frau
verheiratet mit einem Kerle der bei
einem Anlagenbauer in Langensalza ist
ja bevor sie sich Gummi anschauen
schauen Sie sich unsere Wärmepumpen an
die gehen bis 240 Grad da kann man viel
mehr machen
diese Wärmepumpe
was Nettes sagt und meint Pumpe wir
haben eine wir haben Wärmepumpen für
unsere Industriekunden aber die Kamera
bestimmt auch adaptieren für
Haushaltshilfe
radiatorenheizung nehmen 240 Grad dann
machen wir Dampf so jetzt kriegt die
Frau Rente ich bin noch voll bewusst
tätig und wir werden zusammen vom
Finanzamt in Eisenach veranlagt und die
Meldung geht an die Rentenkasse
und da ist noch eine Grenze drin das hat
nichts mit der Hinzuverdienstgrenze zu
tun sondern mit der gemeinsamen
Veranlagung und da gibt es dann auf
diesen 15 seitigen Rentenbescheid von
meiner Frau eine Position wo drin steht
kürzer des Zuschlags der Rente für
langfristig für langjährig Versicherte
das Ding wird rausgekürzt das sind 156
Euro im Monat und da hat mir der junge
Mann gesagt ja ihre Frau wird zusammen
mit Ihnen veranlagt und zwar zu 100
Prozent nicht die Hälfte des gesamten
gemeinsamen veranlagten Einkommens
sondern sie kriegt alles in die
Berechnung rein und ab 1900 Euro im
Monat geht es los dass diese Beitrag
zusammengekürzt wird und bei 2500 Euro
im Monat würde komplett gekürzt ist sehr
komplex könnte ich habe ein Gewissen
Intelligenzquotienten und ich habe lange
gebraucht bis ich das verstanden habe
und das ist es so es hat sie diesen
Zuschlag bekommen
Beamten das so geschrieben haben und
eigentlich von der gesetzlichen Rente
nichts haben was die Modifikation angeht
kriegt sie jetzt wieder abgezogen
so müsste man sich doch eigentlich wenn
man dafür indirekt verantwortlich ist
für schämen oder der Punkt ist noch eins
zur Scholz das Thema ist nämlich mit
dieser
Rentenversicherung mit der Steuer die da
kommt das wird ja immer mehr ich gehe 29
in Rente und ich muss da mehr
steuerlichen Anteil bezahlen wenn man
jetzt zu zweit ist um bekommt Rente dann
hat man in der Zusammenveranlagung je
später man man in Rente kommt umso mehr
hören Anteile und irgendwann mal hat so
ein verheiratetes Pärchen 1900 Euro zu
versteuerndes Einkommen im Monat
und dann geht es los ab 1900 Euro das
Land dieser Zuschlag für langjährig
Versicherte oder der Zuschlag für die
Grundrente gekürzt wird weil man früher
wo es noch kein Mindestlohn gegeben hat
einfach mit fünf Euro 40 in Thüringen
abgespeist worden ist Thüringen hat den
Ruf und es ist auch Niedriglohn Land zu
sein schönen Dank für die Frage wollen
sie noch was sagen ich habe nur nach
hinten gehört dass das Thema
das Thema ist ja für die weiterkommenden
Rentner ein Thema weil diese diese 1900
Euro wenn sie dann für die die in Rente
sind reinschauen das ist der Rentenpunkt
den sie haben diese 37 Euro die werden
mit 47 Faktor 47 multipliziert und dann
kommt diese 1900 € raus
habe ich verstanden worum es geht es
geht darum von der Politiker Gilde in
Berlin
diesen Zuschlag bekommen hat und nur
weil sie privat Glück gehabt hat mit mir
verheiratet zu sein darf bei den Anlagen
aber dann lassen Sie bei den
Bundeskanzler was dazu sagen
Bürgermeister so schönen Dank also ich
habe versucht zu folgen und ich glaube
dass ich einigermaßen mitgekommen bin
deshalb will ich mehrere Punkten kurz
was sagen damit noch viele dran kommen
erstens ich stimme Ihnen zu dass es
Löhne von 540 gegeben hat war nicht in
Ordnung sondern muss mit klaren Worten
zu sagen eine Schweinerei
und deshalb will ich
deshalb habe ich mich so sehr für den
Mindestlohn eingesetzt und wenn Sie sich
erinnern am Anfang unseres Gesprächs
hier war die erste Frage zumindestlohn
aber aus der Perspektive ob er nicht
vielleicht zu hoch ist also ich finde
dass wir ein Mindestlohn eingeführt
haben es richtig ist auch nicht zu hoch
sondern er ist gemessen an dem was man
gerne verdienen würde sogar da wird man
ja nicht von reich sondern das ist ganz
was anderes wenn ich das dazu sagen darf
von 12 € Mindestlohn bei 40 Stunden
Woche wenn ich mich nicht verrechnet
habe sind 2080 € brutto das ist für eine
40 Stunden Woche das kommt dann dabei
raus also Reichtum ist was anderes und
deshalb ist das natürlich gut dass wir
das gemacht haben das hilft aber
natürlich nicht rückwärts
und deshalb haben wir das gemacht was
die angesprochen haben nämlich eine
Grundrente eingeführt das heißt dass
jemand eine Rente kriegt für die er
keinen Beitrag bezahlt hat weil wir
sagen war aber lange erwerbstätig und
deshalb ist das irgendwie nicht gut mit
der Rente
das ist technisch gar nicht so einfach
weil wir natürlich von niemandem Wissen
hat er oder sie wenig verdient weil man
drei Stunden die Woche gearbeitet hat
oder wenig verdient weil man pro Stunde
wenig Geld gekriegt hat das sind ja zwei
ganz unterschiedliche Lebens
Sachverhalte aber die sehen bei der
Rentenversicherung komplett identisch
aus der steht nämlich immer die gleiche
Summe
und deshalb haben wir überlegt wie
machen wir das und haben darüber
übrigens drei Jahre in der letzten
Koalition verhandelt zwei zweieinhalb
waren es glaube ich
ich habe da Nächte mit zugebracht das
wird ja jetzt immer erzählt dass da ist
neu das koalitionsfahren und nachts
stattfinden also ich hatte schon viele
schlaflose Nächte auf früher
und das war eins dieser Themen die wir
über ganz lange Zeit und dann auch über
mehrere Nächte immer wieder neu
verhandelt haben mit ganz vielen
Kompromissen das will ich dazu sagen
aber wo es mir und meinen
sozialdemokratischen Freunden ganz
wichtig war dass wir das überhaupt
hinkriegen eine Aufstockung einer
geringen Rente bei langer
Erwerbstätigkeit das ist ja letztendlich
die Idee dahinter aber das ist dann
etwas was natürlich einkommensabhängig
ist weil es gibt viele Fälle es gibt
auch Leute
ich hätte jetzt beinahe gesagt wie mich
obwohl es nicht ganz stimmt die haben
auch mal
Rentenversicherungsbeiträge gezahlt
aber sehr viel weil ich immer sehr viel
verdient hat und auch freiwillig
und ich bin auch nachtversichert worden
also solche Sachen sind passiert durch
das aber durch die Tatsache dass ich
jetzt seit 1998 Berufspolitiker bin wird
der größte Teil meiner Altersversorgung
aus diesen Ansprüchen entstehen die ich
gewonnen habe als Abgeordneter als
als Hamburger Bürgermeister als Minister
und als Bundeskanzler
aber wenn man einen Mann nur mein
Rentenbescheid anguckt dann ist der zwar
nicht schlecht aber natürlich nur wie
wenn jemand ich weiß nicht was das so
alles zusammen ist 15 16 Jahre im
Ergebnis Sozialversicherungsbeiträge
gezahlt hat und dann den Höchstbeitrag
sieht dann nicht so doll aus trotzdem
habe ich ganz viel Geld im Alter und
wenn das jetzt noch ein bisschen weniger
wäre als dass ich jetzt hätte dann würde
ich irgendwann vielleicht eine
aufstockungsleistung kriegen weil man
nur mein Rentenbescheid anguckt und sagt
ist aber eine geringe Rente obwohl ich
ein Vielfaches an Altersversorgung habe
aus dem was ich aus den anderen
Ansprüchen habe und da gibt es noch
andere auch viele Beamte in Deutschland
haben mal eine Zeit lang
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge gezahlt die
stehen dann Statistik mit 300 Euro Rente
aber die sind natürlich nicht arm weil
ja ihre eigentliche alterseinkunft die
ist die sie aus der Pension haben und
deshalb war das für uns so schwer wie
finden wir ein System das hin dagegen
und darum gibt es eine
einkommensgegenrechnung die führt
natürlich dazu
ohne dass jetzt ihre Berechnung
nachvollziehen kann dass wenn da in
einer Familie zwei Einkommen sind eine
einkommensgegenrechnung stattfinden kann
und wenn das Einkommen ganz ordentlich
ist bis zu sein scheint dann ist das so
dass das natürlich Auswirkungen für
diese Aufstockung der Rente weil man zu
wenig Rente hat
haben muss so
gefällt Ihnen wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht
aber ich wollte ihn erklären wie es dazu
gekommen ist und dass das trotz der
Tatsache dass ich mir manches noch hätte
schöner vorstellen können das Ergebnis
der Beratung damals war und dass da
viele Leute sich viele Gedanken gemacht
haben wie kriegt man es eigentlich hin
zur Besteuerung habe ich vorhin schon
alles gesagt
hätten wir nicht haben müssen aber
wir müssen das Bundesverfassungsgericht
beachten
wir würden wir würden versuchen mal mit
jemandem anderen weiterzumachen immer
weiter aber
die Briefe werden nachher separat
übergeben eingesammelt wie auch immer
das kriegen wir hin wir machen jetzt mal
hier vorne weiter Paul wenn du da bist
genau ich gehe mal wieder hier rüber
guten Abend Herr Bundeskanzler ich komme
aus Eisenach ich bin mit meinem Mann
hier zu Gast und möchte sie auch nicht
so lange unterhalten aber ich konnte
durch Krankheit mit 63 in Rente gehen
ich muss weiter arbeiten ich habe eine
kleine Gaststätten Eisenach weil meine
Rente vorne und hinten nicht reicht ich
habe zu DDR-Zeiten 77 angefangen zu
lernen habe immer in der Gastronomie
gearbeitet jedes Wochenende Weihnachten
Silvester wenn alle anderen gefeiert
haben ich habe heute keine 900 € Rente
ich bin jetzt 20 Jahre selbstständig
gewesen und bin auch immer noch da
bezahle ich alleine Krankenkasse 55 bei
Tag und ich will es nicht mehr wie es
weitergehen soll mein Mann ist privater
Taxifahrer der ist auch Renten und fährt
auch trotzdem weiter weil sonst kann man
sich gar nichts mehr gönnen das kann
sich ja eigentlich nicht sein wenn ich
dann auf der anderen Seite die Leute am
Bahnhof rum stehen sehe mit nur Büchse
Bier die nicht arbeiten Burger Geld ist
doch
herrlich kann ich ja langsam nicht mehr
mitkommen
[Musik]
sehr gut dass sie so fleißig sind das
haben sie ihr Leben lang durchgehalten
das finde ich ist auch etwas was ich
wirklich immer sehr beeindruckend finde
und ich teile das also ich kenne ganz
viele die schwer schuften nie so richtig
auf dem grünen Zweig gekommen sind und
die gucken natürlich ganz besonders
verärgert wenn andere nicht gucken was
kann man dann tun wo kann man anpacken
und ich meine wir reden hier mehrfach
über Arbeitskräfte Mangel da wird ja
vielleicht der ein oder andere mal sagen
können so jetzt ist meine Zeit gekommen
nicht so das werbe ich auch für
was die
Frage betrifft wie jetzt ihr
Renteneinkommen zustande gekommen ist
das kann ich natürlich nicht gut
beurteilen ich weiß ja auch nicht ob sie
während der Selbständigkeit haben Sie
wahrscheinlich keine Beiträge mehr gibt
ziemlich gut also sie haben den
Grundbeitrag immerhin weiter gezahlt
dadurch ist es immerhin so viel aber
natürlich ist es so dass das eine Sache
ist die mich auch sehr besorgt wir
denken jetzt darüber nach wie kann man
eigentlich sicherstellen dass jemand der
zum Beispiel sehr große Teile seines
Lebens selbstständig war aber nichts
fürs Alter vorgesorgt hat weil die nicht
in die Rente einzahlen dass das besser
läuft und dafür haben wir eine Idee wie
man das machen kann auch
unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten weil
ehrlicherweise fällt einem das ja schwer
wenn man nicht so viel hat dann noch was
abzuknapsen aber trotzdem müssen wir das
irgendwie machen damit das im Alter
irgendwie hinhaut und da ist eine sind
wir dran wie wir was entwickeln können
das hilft ihnen nicht mehr aber denen
die vielleicht 20 30 Jahre selbstständig
waren und in der Zeit zu wenig fürs
Alter vorgesorgt haben dann in der
Zukunft
was die
Frage betrifft der Krankenversicherung
da sind sie wie sie gesagt haben privat
krankenversichert und das ist natürlich
sehr teuer vor allem im Alter
wir haben ein System wo wir
Gesetze haben die sollen verhindern dass
man das betrifft gar nicht so viel die
Selbstständigen aber dass man wenn man
berufstätig ist und viel Geld verdient
aus der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
rausgeht und die dann billigeren
Beiträge in der privaten
Krankenversicherung zahlt und dann wenn
es teuer wird wieder zurückgeht weil das
geht dann für den Laden gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung nicht gut aus aber
man muss natürlich was tun für Leute die
diese hohen Beiträge gar nicht zahlen
können deshalb haben wir ein Gesetz
gemacht
das vorsieht dass man bei seiner
privaten Krankenkasse verlangen kann
quasi zum
die Leistung die es bei der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung gibt zu kriegen und
dafür einen kleineren Beitrag zu zahlen
das müssen die auch machen das machen
die nicht gerne ich kann Ihnen sagen ich
bin ja Abgeordneter ich kriege immer
wieder Briefe von Bürgern die mir
erzählen wie schlecht sie da behandelt
werden weil die Sonne Kunden nicht haben
wollen
kriege ich bestimmt jetzt Protestbriefe
von den privaten Krankenversicherungen
sie behandeln alle Blenden dann sagen
wir gucken wir mal aber ich will gern
sagen das ist das was wir als Gesetz
geregelt haben und wir haben sogar eine
Regelung dass für Leute die ganz wenig
haben da noch mindest und Mini Beiträge
möglich sind übrigens auch für
Selbstständige die wenig verdienen aber
da würde ich Sie bitten dass sie das mal
für sich erörtern es wird aber nicht
schön weil ich das Ihnen jetzt auch
nicht als Illusion erzählen will da habe
ich schon ganz schön traurige Briefe
gekriegt von einigen wie man sie
behandelt wenn sie sagen ich möchte
gerne zum Grundtarif in der privaten
Krankenversicherung sein aber da haben
sie mich auf ihrer Seite und wenn sie
schlecht behandelt werden dürfen sie
sich an mich wenden
aber dann müsste ich 3000 € im Jahr
erstmal selbst finanzieren wenn du mir
wenn ich irgendwelche Medikamente oder
krank sowas schreiben Sie es mir
noch meine Rückmeldung
[Applaus]
auf jeden Fall ja
ich würde sagen wir gucken noch mal ähm
ohne despektiere dich zu sein auf ein
paar jüngere Leute die auch hier sind
vielleicht das war jetzt gar nicht so
gemeint also naja
ich würde mal sagen da geht das Mikro
hin zu der Dame im beigen Mantel
schönen guten Tag mein Name ist Helena
Schneider und ich bin Schülerin an einem
Gymnasium in Weimar und ich komme jetzt
in die elfte Klasse und da kommt ein
bisschen dann die Frage auf Abitur und
es ist tatsächlich so dass ich mich auch
häufig mit Freunden aus anderen
Bundesländern unterhalte und wenn es
dann zum Abitur geht dann kommt immer
sehr schnell bei euch in Thüringen das
Abitur ist ja ziemlich leicht deswegen
kommen die guten Abitur Noten Zustande
in Bayern heißt es dann aber die
abituren sind so gut weil ihr schlau
seid und das finde ich nicht fair und
deswegen wollte ich mal fragen wie das
denn mit einem Zentralabitur aussieht wo
vom Bund an am selben Tag alle
Abiturienten die gleichen Aufgaben
bearbeiten damit das Abitur einfach
vergleichbar wird
da haben sie jetzt in ein Wespennest
gestoßen aber hier auch viel Beifall
gekriegt also ich finde manches Abitur
für das Leute ganz schön schwer arbeiten
und auch ganz schön viel können müssen
wird ganz schön schlecht geredet und
zwar zu Unrecht und deshalb glaube ich
auch dass die Vorurteile die da
verbreitet sind sich nicht wirklich alle
bestätigen lassen wir sind aber
natürlich ein Land in dem es den
bildungsförderalismus gibt das heißt die
Bildung ist Sache der 16 Länder nun sind
einige der Länder größer als Mann drin
manche Mitgliedsstaaten der Europäischen
Union und zwar auch solche die
erfolgreich sind wenn man mal Finnland
anguckt oder Dänemark oder Schweden oder
so aber es ist trotzdem etwas was wir im
Blick haben müssen manchmal habe ich den
Eindruck wenn wir eine Volksabstimmung
machen würden soll Bildung der Bund
machen gibt es 80% dafür
aber ich will mal vorher sagen die
Grundgesetzänderung kommt nie zustande
und deshalb
sollten wir die Tatsache dass es auch
viele Vorteile hat dass es ein
Föderalismus gibt nutzen denn das
bedeutet ja auch dass man Sachen machen
kann an denen die anderen eigentlich
hindern können also das hat mir
jedenfalls als ich mal länderchef war
ganz gut gefallen und hat glaube ich
auch dazu geführt dass dort jetzt die
Bildungsergebnisse immer besser werden
wegen der Entscheidung die wir
seinerzeit getroffen haben was ist das
das gemeinsame Abitur betrifft es gibt
gemeinsame Standards auf die sie sich
verständigt haben wenn ich das richtig
im Kopf habe gibt es eine restfrage die
geklärt werden muss wo ich sage jetzt
macht mal Leute ob man wie viele
Leistungskurse glaube ich es geben darf
zwei oder drei ich sag würfelt es aus es
ist voll egal ob es zwei oder drei sind
hauptsache es ist einheitlich weil dann
kann niemand mehr was sagen dass die
Dinge unterschiedlich sind es gibt auch
bestimmte Fragen die mit eingemischt
werden sollen in die Abiturprüfung und
die dann bundesweit einheitlich sind da
halten sich die Länder Unterschied lich
intensiv dran das ist praktisch ein
Vorschlag aber es wird schon was dafür
getan das ist ein einheitliches Abitur
in Deutschland gibt und da Deutschland
immer ein föderaler Staat war sogar ein
Staat der noch vor 1871 gar keinen
zentral statt hatte
ist es schon eine große Leistung dass
wir eigentlich immer ein einheitliches
von allen akzeptiertes Abitur hatten das
ist eine historische Leistung des
deutschen Föderalismus wir waren also
einheitlicher beim Abitur
bevor wir überhaupt ein Land waren also
das gehört zur Geschichte irgendwie dazu
deshalb wunder ich mich immer warum das
jetzt so schwer ist wo es ja eigentlich
geht die Sachen auch zu Ende zu kriegen
und ein einheitliches zentralabitur
ich glaube da müssten wir einen großen
Büroturm in Berlin mieten wo dann lauter
Beamte sitzen und sich über die
gemeinsamen Abitur Fragen streiten also
jedenfalls die Fantasie wie das geht die
habe ich noch nicht ganz weil es müssen
ja am Ende 16 mal Leute ja sagen deshalb
bin ich aber dafür dass man das
eigentlich Anliegen von ihnen
einheitliche ausgangskriterium
Vergleichbarkeit des Abiturs und weg mit
den forturteilen sie haben recht
[Applaus]
weißen
hallo hi Felix Erich mein Name noch
keine Rentenfrage
genau ich habe eigentlich eine Frage von
einer Freundin die gerade in Wien im
Urlaub ist die hatte mir die mitgegeben
und es geht um die das Thema die
Wiedereinführung der
wohngemeinnützigkeit die wurde ja im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart aber jetzt
wurden im Juni erstmal nur so ein paar
Eckpunkte irgendwie festgelegt aber so
richtig fehlt noch irgendwie eine
Finanzierung es gab drei Optionen aber
es gibt immer noch keine richtige
Perspektive und jetzt war eigentlich die
Frage an Sie mir steht's denn dazu und
wie kann es denn in Zukunft dann auch
zur Einführung kommen oder
Wiedereinführung der
wohngemeinschaftlichkeit sie haben den
sozialen Wohnungsbau von schon
angesprochen
wir wollen das machen
können dich alle Sachen im ersten Jahr
der Regierung ordentlich im zweiten
machen aber bevor die Legislaturperiode
zu Ende ist soll es passiert sein und es
gibt auch sehr konkretisierte
Vorstellungen dazu also deshalb will ich
die kurze Antwort auf diese Frage geben
ich bin eigentlich sicher dass das kommt
das war Rekordzeit die Antwort stark das
schaffen wir noch mehr und ich würde
sagen wir gehen mal nach hier vorne die
Frau im hellblauen Hemd bekommt auch ein
Mikrofon
von Sabrina mein Name ist Dorothea Herz
ich komme aus dem Eichsfeld und mir geht
es um meine Kinder und Enkel also
speziell meine Enkel ich habe große
Sorge dass das Niveau des
Bildungssystems
immer weiter nach unten geht ganz
speziell geht es mir darum um die Kinder
wo ich auch ein Enkel habe der zur
Corona Zeit in der Schule gekommen ist
nur zu Hause beschult werden musste
es gibt zwar Förderprogramme die die
Schulen abrufen können aber die können
gar nicht genutzt werden weil keine
Lehrer da sind weil keine
Pädagogen da sind die sich darum kümmern
können um diesen bildungsrückstand
wieder aufzuholen und das macht mir
wirklich echt große Sorgen weil die
Kinder haben ja auch keine Zeit das
irgendwo nachzuholen
ich habe zum Beispiel einen Vorschlag
wäre es nicht möglich die ganzen Gelder
die wirklich ich weiß dass von den
LehrerInnen und die bei meinen Kindern
mein Enkeln unterrichten das ist Geld
zwar irgendwo zur Verfügung steht aber
wäre es nicht möglich dass auch private
Nachhilfestunden oder sowas finanziert
werden können mit diesen Budget was ja
beschlossen ist von ihnen also so diese
Bildungs
Corona Hilfe oder ich weiß nicht genau
wie das heißt
ja wir haben wie sie berichten
Gelder zur Verfügung gestellt damit die
jungen Leute die Kinder und Jugendlichen
nachholen können was sie während Corona
Corona verloren haben da geht es nicht
nur um Schulstoff da geht es auch um
andere Sachen Bewegung Freunde und alles
das was wichtig ist damit man gut
aufwachsen kann und eine glückliche
Zukunft hat und haben da ganz viele
Programme möglich gemacht die natürlich
umgesetzt werden müssen von Ländern und
Gemeinden und wir sehen auch die Gelder
werden unterschiedlich intensiv
abgerufen können das aber nicht ändern
dass das vor Ort ist aber es gibt bei
vielen dieser Programme ob das auch für
Nachhilfe gilt weiß ich nicht genau aber
ich vermute mal dass man das jedenfalls
in bestimmten
Vereinsstrukturen jedenfalls machen
könnte gibt es auch Möglichkeiten dass
es nicht der Staat machen muss sondern
auch Einrichtung machen können denn wir
haben ja auch Sportvereine und
freizeitvereine mit eingebunden die
bestimmte Dinge machen können und wenn
die das zum Beispiel in die Hand nehmen
dann würde das auch gehen deshalb habe
ich schon den Eindruck das ginge ganz
genau weiß es natürlich nicht weil ich
jetzt nicht die Förderbescheide
ausgestellt habe aber ich habe den
Eindruck da wer was drin
also in Brandenburg ist es nicht möglich
also in der Schule und mein Enkel Moment
da ist gerade kein Mikro Abgeordnete aus
dem landebrandenburg sind wenn das Ihre
Frage ist frage ich mal nach okay wenn
wir uns Mühe geben haben wir schaffen
wir vielleicht noch zwei wenn die Frage
kurz ist und die Antwort vielleicht
entsprechend auch dieser junge Mann
[Gelächter]
mein Name ist Stefan Dill ich bin
selbstständiger Handelsvertreter und
habe Kundschaft Mittelstand in
Ostthüringen und Stichworte sind
Abhängigkeit von China
automotive Zulieferer und OEMs und die
Firma die die ich gut kenne Stellen
Magnete her die in der Sitzverstellung
bei den automotiven bei dem Fahrzeugen
eingesetzt werden das sind sehr
traditionelle Firma die jetzt aber die
Stellen abbauen muss die schließen muss
das sind 60 Prozent der Belegschaft muss
gehen der Grund ist
dass die Automobil also OEMs waren froh
als in Shanghai der Hafen zu war Gott
sei Dank
Audi BMW wer auch immer euch in
Ostthüringen gibt es wir kaufen eure
Produkte super und die Ostthüringer
waren dann froh haben dann auch schön
mit aufgelegt hat das ist jetzt richtig
gut
und dann war in Shanghai der Hafen
wieder offen die lockdown-zeit war
vorbei und Wiener heiße Kartoffel hat
man diese
sag mal ostdeutschen Produzenten fallen
gelassen und weil das ein Prozent
billiger war ist man nach China gegangen
mit der Folge dass der Standort 80 Jahre
Tradition die einzigen in Europa
schließen jetzt diese Sparte und wenn
dann wieder mal irgendwie China mit
China irgendwas ist kommen die OEMs und
sagen ja es geht nicht die Bänder stehen
Kurzarbeit Fördermittel ja also und die
Aussage der Ostthüringer war wenn die
OMs die Auflage hätten wenigstens 10%
ihrer Produkte zu FIFA 17 und zu sagen
okay meinetwegen 80% China 90 % und 10 %
von diesen einen Produzenten die dann
ausgelastet ausgelastet bis dort hinaus
also da wäre wirklich eine Zukunft da
und hätte auch eine Alternative und das
erstaunlich ist eben dass man sagt die
sprechen deutsch die haben eine Qualität
da kann man mal kurz anrufen das war
alles egal man ist wirklich für 10 oder
30 Cent ist man dann nach China gegangen
wo ist da die Verantwortung der großen
Automobilindustrie wenn es heißt wir
wollen unabhängiger werden von China
also das ist passt nicht zusammen ja ich
will Ihnen gerne Rechte reine Kapital
und das auch die Automobilzulieferer ist
ganz schwierig es zu wenig zum Sterben
so viel zu sterben zu wenig zum Leben
finde ich und da ist wirklich der reine
Kapitalismus also das sind die am Ende
verdient wirklich nur der der das Auto
ausliefert das eine ganz schwierige
Geschichte und in dem Fall führt dazu
dass es zum Haus gekommen ist ja ich
will ihn gerne Recht geben und ich
wunder mich auch das will ich dazu sagen
ich meine dass alle aufs Geld gucken das
ist ein Teil der Wirtschaft und wer sich
mal so ein Produkt aus Deutschland
anguckt der wird sehen da sind tausende
Teile aus aller Welt dabei das ist ein
Teil unserer Wirtschaftskraft dass das
so ist und wir werden nicht so
erfolgreich wenn es nicht so wäre
aber gleichzeitig müssten ja nur
eigentlich alle gelernt haben dass die
es gibt immer so schöne Schlagworte die
Diversifizierung von Lieferketten einen
Sinn macht damit man nicht in einseitige
Abhängigkeit Gerät das hat Konsequenzen
solche dass man solche
Alternativen Hersteller am Leben hält im
eigenen Interesse und das hat
Konsequenzen dass man selbst wenn man
zwei Billiglohn Produzenten in zwei
unterschiedlichen Regionen der Welt hat
trotzdem mehr Zeit als wenn man auf
einen setzt
aber es ist richtig und das ist aber
etwas was wir alle im Blick haben müssen
wenn wir aus dem Dingen die wir jetzt
gelernt haben als Volkswirtschaft und
das ist dann ja nicht nur der Staat
sondern unglaublich viele Unternehmen
die Konsequenz ziehen dass man nicht
abhängig sein sollte von einem
Lieferanten von einer Weltregion als
lieferregion von einem Markt wohin man
verkauft oder man investiert dann
bedeutet das natürlich dass alles ein
bisschen teurer wird das werden wir dann
auch persönlich spüren denn dass das
alles so billig war in den letzten
Jahren hat ja genau daran gelegen dass
unsere Unternehmen ganz oft solche
Entscheidungen getroffen haben und wenn
wir sagen wir wollen es aber auch ein
bisschen sicherer haben dann wird es
auch ein bisschen teurer das werden wir
schon irgendwann dann spüren aber mein
Rat an die Unternehmen ist der den sie
auch quasi geben das ist nicht schlau
das will ich ausdrücklich sagen und ich
habe schon einen Eindruck dass im Großen
und Ganzen da einen Umdenken stattfindet
aber eben nicht überall und bei jeder
Gelegenheit und ihr Beispiel ist ein
negatives in dieser Hinsicht dass mich
auch persönlich bedrückt und dessen
Logik ich auch nicht verstehe
ja es geht ums Geld ja
ich habe ich spreche mit denen ich frag
mal ja aber anweisen kann ich Ihnen
nichts und ich finde das sollten wir
auch nicht einführen dass der
Bundeskanzler bestimmt wo eingekauft
wird aber ich hoffe er schaut es hat
jemand für sie mitgeschrieben die ganzen
Aufgaben wo Sie nachfragen müssen und
was alles noch mal zu klären ist diverse
Briefe sind noch zu übergeben aber 90
Minuten gehen schnell rum gefühlt haben
wir viel geschafft aber irgendwie auch
nicht also längst nicht alles sind noch
so viele Hände oben ich finde es schön
dass Sie hier sind hier waren Fragen
stellen ich glaube wir dürfen nicht
aufhören zu diskutieren Fragen zu
stellen Dinge zu hinterfragen und es ist
gut wenn man sich auf einer Ebene
begegnen kann die eben auf Augenhöhe ist
und ähm auch respektvoll miteinander
umgeht danke schön dafür dass das heute
abend möglich war ähm es hat mir Spaß
gemacht hier in meiner Heimatstadt
Erfurt und ich hoffe den Bundeskanzler
hat auch Spaß gemacht und vor allem hat
er viel mitgenommen viel Arbeit bitte
auch ja unbedingt dann vielen vielen
Dank dafür
ja das war es also das kanzlergespräch
live aus dem MegaPark in Erfurt und live
eben auch übertragen hier bei Phoenix
vielleicht noch mal so ganz kurz was er
alles angesprochen hat das war
Atomausstieg heizungsgesetz
soziale Abstieg waren viele Fragen es
ging um die Rente es ging um den
Mindestlohn und auch viele persönliche
Betroffenheiten die wir dort eben
mitbekommen haben und das möchte ich
jetzt ein bisschen mit Volker Kronenberg
Politikwissenschaftler von der
Universität in Bonn diskutieren
vielleicht mal ganz grob gefragt wie hat
der Kanzler in diesen 90 Minuten in
diesem Bürgerdialog in diesem Kanzler
Gespräch gewirkt
er ist so aufgetreten wie wir ihn kennen
er war sehr nüchtern er war sehr
sachorientiert er hat meine Beobachtung
über weite Strecken gerade zu Beginn
sehr viele Zahlen sehr viele Fakten
präsentiert um eben deutlich zu machen
ich weiß was euch beschäftigt ich weiß
in vielen Fragen drin oder zumindest den
einen absolut deswegen viele Zahlen
viele Fakten er hat das Präsent worum es
geht vielleicht haben würde man sagen
manchmal auch zu viel stellenweise
konnte man zumal in der ersten Stunde
den ersten 60 Minuten nachher wirkte er
darauf zum Schluss hin etwas gelöst
etwas zugewandter noch auch von der
Mimik und von seiner Intonation manchmal
war es vielleicht auch ein wenig allzu
Fakten zahlenlastig Kanzler Gespräch
Bürgerdialog manchmal hätte man auch
gedacht etwas mehr sagen wir mal eben
auch Zugewandtheit aber das war doch
eben der Scholz gerade auch der
Bundeskanzler wie man ihn kennt das war
sehr dicht es war sehr sachlich es wurde
eigentlich nie wirklich polemisch es
wurde nicht wirklich konfrontativ und
interessant auch dass manche Themen sie
haben ja die wesentlichen schon genannt
dann irgendwie explizit so gar nicht
Erwähnung genau da wollte ich jetzt noch
mal drauf hinaus und das ist ja auch
wirklich die Frage zum Beispiel die
Flüchtlingsproblematik das ist ja ein
Punkt mit dem beispielsweise die AFD die
gerade in Thüringen auch in Erfurt sehr
sehr stark in den Umfragen ist auch
gerne das aus Tablet bringt warum wurde
das hier nicht angesprochen erwartet man
da vom Kanzler nichts oder wo was
vermuten sie
ich vermute es wurde jetzt wegen der
Veranstaltung gesagt jetzt war das
Losverfahren insofern nicht
repräsentativ keine Kriterien das war
mit Sicherheit jetzt auch nicht
irgendwie gestellt dann war es offenbar
Zufall denn es ist wie sie sagen das
zeigen die Umfragen das zeigt die
Stimmung vor Ort das ist Thüringen der
Sachsen-Anhalt aber natürlich auch
weiter darüber hinaus in anderen
Regionen da ist das Thema Flucht
Migration Integration Herausforderung
Defizite muss man es anders machen wie
gehen wir mit dem Thema um das ist dort
vor Orden wichtiges Thema aber das ist
ja auch bundesweit nehmen wir die
Innenministerin die diskussionsvorstöße
aus rein der CDU der Union CSU anderes
das ist ja eines der Top-Themen will man
sagen wie gehen wir mit diesen
Herausforderungen um dass das jetzt 90
Minuten so gar nicht Erwähnung gefunden
hat war dann ja weiß ich nicht
vermutlich eben Zufall es hätte auf
jeden Fall als Thema mit Sicherheit
in diese Runde gehört denn es bewegt die
Menschen vor etwas was die Leute bewegt
und wonach auch gefragt wurde ist zum
Beispiel die Energiewende die wir jetzt
in Deutschland ja haben die verkündet
wurde und da gab es dann ja fragen warum
steigen wir uns da Atomkraft aus warum
ist der Verbrennermotor sozusagen am
Ende seiner Laufzeit Angela gelangt und
wie steht es eigentlich mit dem
heizungsgesetz so ein bisschen diese
Machtlosigkeit hatten Sie das Gefühl
dass der Kanzler den Menschen die dort
vor Ort waren die es vielleicht auch
gesehen haben ein bisschen diese
Machtlosigkeit nehmen konnte
die gefühlte Machtlosigkeit
nein an dieser Stelle bei aller Fakten
Sicherheit und hat ja diese
Zusammenhänge manchmal auch durch Umwege
ja im Grunde auch immer demonstriert
aber da blieb dann doch auch immer eine
gewisse kühle Distanz also die Antwort
auf diese Frage war ja dann also wenn
wir jetzt planen und bauen und dann in
so und so viel Jahren da hätte jetzt so
jemand wie Markus würde der das ja
gerade am Wochenende im Sommer Interview
heute gesagt nee das geht dann mit
Brennstäben die holen wir aus dem
Ausland das dauert natürlich woran die
neu bauen das wäre dann vermutlich auch
jetzt als Beispiel genannt Söder während
andere Zugang auch gewesen hier ist Holz
sich auch treu geblieben so kennt man
sich auch so er kann er würde auch sagen
so ist auch in dieses Amt gekommen so
hat er eine Mehrheit auch hinter sich
dann letztendlich dann vereinen können
durch diese Ampelkoalition nein also
wirklich
die Sorgen nehmen bei aller
faktensicherheit an der ein oder anderen
Stelle nicht auf der anderen Seite wir
haben schon gesagt viele freundliche
Gesichter auch viel nicken auch Applaus
das schon aber es blieb dann doch immer
irgendwo über weite Strecken so eine
distanzes hatte dann sehr viel auch von
dozieren manchmal hätte man auch gesagt
mach es kürzer zum Schluss hin kam dann
mal einer Antwort die dann zehn Sekunden
das war die große Ausnahme manchmal über
Minuten hinweg da wäre mir Lebendigkeit
glaube ich für das Format auch durchaus
hilfreich gewesen
der spricht natürlich aus der Opposition
der muss nicht handeln der spricht für
eine Partei hatten sie an der ein oder
anderen Stelle das vielleicht jetzt so
als kurze letzte Frage das Gefühl dass
der Kanzler eben auch bei all seinen
Antworten immer im Hintergrund und
Hinterkopf hatte ich bin ja in einer
Koalition die sich nicht immer einig ist
ich darf jetzt hier nichts sagen was
sozusagen noch möglicherweise das Feuer
weiterhinfacht absolut es gab ja
kritische wir haben gesagt keine
polemischen aber ein zwei kritische
Fragen ist das mit der Entwicklungshilfe
nur notwendig Frau Berg dort und dann
Wirtschaftsminister dort da war ja schon
Leidenschaft spürt da hat er ja sehr
stark verteidigt und das war dann das
Zusammenhalten genau wie sie sagen einer
Ampelkoalition Koalition wieder Willen
die natürlich ja auch es schwer hatte in
den Monaten vor der Sommerpause und nun
wirklich auch jetzt wieder doch
sicherlich schwere Wochen vor sich hat
hier ist ja der Integrator hier hat er
im Grunde die rein geschlossen hier ist
er als derjenige
aufgetreten der das Zusammenhalten will
ja hat er dann aber sozusagen diese Nähe
und diese Klarheit natürlich an der
Stelle dann auch vermissen lassen da ist
die SPD pur auch nicht durchgekommen das
sind natürlich alles Fragen die dann ihm
dann auch wieder einholen werden in den
nächsten Tagen und Wochen und Monaten
ganz kurz zum Schluss hat Herr Kronberg
hat der Kanzler irgendwas gesagt heute
Abend was sie überrascht hat oder wo sie
jetzt sagen würden das ist jetzt noch
mal neuer Aspekt kann ich noch nicht so
nein das hat er nicht und das ist dann
eben auch typisch für diese
Veranstaltung man hätte es sich
womöglich gewünscht oder er hätte mal
einen lautes Lachen oder irgendwie eine
besondere Reaktion das nicht sondern
würden würde sagen er hat es souverän
gemeistert aber man würde sich bei
solchen Formaten vielleicht auch etwas
mehr wünscht nichts an Format oder liegt
es eben auch an der Person er ist ja
eben insgesamt eher der zurückhaltendere
Politiker Typ letzteres aber es war auch
von der von der Anlage von den Fragen
und wie sie präsentiert wurden dann auch
nicht wirklich dass man ihn provoziert
oder herausgefordert oder
herausgekitzelt hat es lag sicherlich an
beiden aber da ist ja auch ein Stück
weit nüchtern Fakten orientiert sachlich
da ist ein Stück weit eben auch in sich
gefangen aber noch einmal er hat das
auch natürlich kultiviert und er steht
heute da wo er steht und das würde er
immer für sich reklamieren er würde auch
sagen abgerechnet wird zum Schluss bei
der nächsten Bundestagswahl und einfach
heute immer bei ihm beobachtbar er hat
die langen Linien im Blick also
sozusagen ein bisschen die Hoffnung
jetzt sind wir in einer schwierigen
Situation gewählt wird wenn nichts
dazwischen kommt 2025 allerdings da
dürfen wir eins nicht vergessen er hat
ja auch noch ein paar Landtagswahlen bzw
seine Partei hat ja auch noch einige
Landtagswahlen zu bestehen vor allen
Dingen in Ostdeutschland gab es da in
diesem Gespräch heute auch die Ansprache
Richtung Ostdeutschland zum Beispiel
Friedrich Merz wurde ja immer wieder mal
kritisiert dass er zu wenig auf den
ersten Blick hat beispielsweise auch mit
seiner Personalauswahl jetzt mit dem
neuen Generalsekretär
gab es dort Ansprachen auch Richtung
Osten Richtung Ostdeutschland er hatte
z.B ja noch mal diese shit verbringen
erwähnt wo er gesagt hat dann nehmen wir
viel Geld in die Hand die werden gebaut
in Sachsen und dann eben auch noch in
Sachsen-Anhalt aber ist das was für die
Menschen
ich würde sagen ja und das weiß er
natürlich auch weil diese Investitionen
ja mit Arbeitsplätzen verbunden ist mit
Neuansiedlungen da entstehen neue
Strukturen da entsteht eine neue Dynamik
die in diesen Regionen wo investiert
wird Sachsen-Anhalt anderswo natürlich
auch sicherlich nottun oder zumindest
sehr positiv wirken das weiß er dass das
der Fall ist ansonsten dezidiert deine
ostdeutsche Ansprache heute nicht bis
auf den Einstieg damit Erfurt dass es
sich gut auskennen und das alles er
wandert oder durchwandert hat also
dezidiert eben nicht aber das noch mal
den Bogen zurück abgerechnet wird am
Schluss und er hat die die
Bundestagswahl vor Augen und das ist
natürlich so weil dann am Ende bei all
den Themen die sie genannt haben er auf
eines natürlich ganz Klar setzen wird
und das ist dann auch das nüchterne
zurückgenommene das das integriert sagen
wir hatten eine so schwere Krise diese
Krise diese Krise aber wir haben das
souverän so und darauf setzt er und
darauf kann er natürlich auch setzen
weil viele Menschen viele Bürgerinnen
und Bürger dann nachher abwägen das
passt zwar nicht und das ist nicht genug
und das aber letztendlich Vertrauen das
hat einer doch ganz gut hingekriegt
darauf setzt da und da ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit auch gar nicht gering
dass das klappen kann das war heute wenn
ich das richtig mitgezählt habe das
neunte kanzlergespräch sozusagen also
ein paar hat er noch weil er will ja bis
zum Ende seiner Legislaturperiode alle
Bundesländer einmal mit einem Kanzler
Gespräch bereist haben vielen Dank
Volker Kronberg von der Universität in
Bonn für die Einschätzung die spannenden
Einschätzung hier im Anschluss an das
Kanzler Gespräch in Erfurt ja liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer und ich
bedanke mich bei Ihnen ganz herzlich
auch fürs zuschauen